Boom.
[inaudible].
This is how we do this.
We have two commercials that we do
before we do the actual podcast,
but a,
they're very informal and you can jump
in at anytime if you feel like if you
have questions,
if you have a comment,
feel free.
The Joe Rogan experience podcast is
brought to you by the flashlight.
If you go to Joe Rogan done,
man,
click on the link for the
flashlight and her in the code name,
Rogan,
you will save yourself 15% off
the number one sex toy for men.
Holla at that.
My boy Justin buckles,
always talking about the flashlight.
Does he have one?
He loves it.
It's fucking palace from Alaska.
Oh,
you need one up there.
It's either that or a seal.
You might get it stolen to borrowed.
That's disgusting.
Borrowed another man's fleshlight rude.
We're also brought to you by [inaudible]
dot com makers of Alpha brain shrink to
Algebra and you need
some Alpha brain alpha.
Do you try it?
You'll like it.
I have no idea.
I'm just saying my brain's Oh,
in your brain you're in.
Alpha brain was,
it's a combination of nutrients that
are designed to enhance your cognitive
function.
It's all like they increase your brain's
ability to produce neurotransmitters
there.
It's called nootropics and Nutro Bexar,
a very,
uh,
it's very,
interesting and fascinating subject to me.
I've been involved in them for years and
I was talking about a bill Romanowski
stuff.
It's called neuro one.
That's how I got into it.
Um,
he makes a great product and he started
making it after he developed a bunch of
concussions from football and
he came up with this mixture.
It's a mixture of
nutrients that a enhanced,
the way his brain worked was having,
uh,
having some issues with that.
So that's a fascinating subject.
If you're interested in nootropics at all,
just Google it.
Please do some research.
Don't just go buy shit.
But if you're interested
in what we're selling,
go to onnit.com it's o,
n,
I t and a checkout Alpha
brain and truth tech,
sport,
shroom,
tech immune,
all the different,
there's,
there's different
supplements for athletics.
There's different supplements
for thinking for your mood.
None of them are illegal.
Every,
you're not going to fail a piss
test and all of them are safe.
It's all explained on,
on at.com and we try to make this as
even and fair as humanly possible.
So when you order 30 pills,
if you don't like it,
you try it.
You don't like it.
You don't have to even return it.
Just say this stuff sucks.
You get your money back 100%.
We're way more concerned with not having
people feel ripped off than we are with
making money.
And I would never sell anything if it
wasn't something that I actually use and
actually believed in.
I take that shit before every show and
we've got some right in here somewhere.
I'll take it eventually,
but uh,
so we'll get to that again.
Take a look at it.
It's a,
it's vitamins there you
said will test positive.
No,
you won't test positive.
It's nothing.
Nothing.
You really have to worry about it and
people in the world actually have to get
tested.
You've got to be small.
A lot of people,
man,
you'd be surprised.
Lately,
especially I talked to so many
people that get tested on the job,
you know,
they get random drug tests for like,
you know people that work for
companies that don't want assholes.
What's working for them and the watch
be fucked up and showing up at work,
cranked out on Meth,
which I totally understand.
But this guy in Columbus,
Ohio,
when I was there with Joey Diaz,
he got,
he's been tested 12 times and two years
and so now he's a big pot too so he
smokes that fake shit.
And now like that shit
is so much worse for you.
What's that shit called?
You bite the head shops that
are not what you're talking.
Yeah and that cannot be good for you but
like it and it kind of sucks is Dick.
He would smoke it and he and I was like,
how long has it lasts?
About three hours and just sit there and
zone out and look at a wall and like it
just sounded awful.
Regular regular jobs where they test,
you suck the fat Dicks,
right.
You're right.
A favors here.
Go to on a.com.
O n n I t use a codename rogue and save
yourself 10% off any and all orders.
We've got a lot of new stuff coming to
that's on the pipes down the pipes on
sweater or something like that.
Transgression experience.
Try my day.
Joe Rogan podcast,
powerful Uriah Faber has joined us derive
favors on a fucking whirlwind tour of
it.
The United States to him publicity for
his book and a four in preparation for
his interim title shot that he's got
coming up and a little over a month right
with and Burrell.
Right about a month.
You are a busy mother fucker cause
I keep hearing you on radio shows.
I keep seeing you places.
I keep seeing all these interviews.
How much publicity if you'd done like
in the last just a couple of weeks.
Uh,
it's been a lot and then
I'm coming off the show too.
So I was filming for three months.
I haven't been home in four months.
Wow.
God,
Damn.
Before that I was traveling too.
So it's been nutty.
How difficult is that
psychologically for you?
I mean,
it's one thing to go away
for an eight week camp,
but when you're doing that show,
it's like 13 weeks,
right?
And then you,
you know,
you're there afterwards doing publicity.
Well,
I should be upbringing where
structure wasn't like the thing,
it wasn't like you got up at this time
in the meal was at this time and this and
that.
It was like whenever you get it done.
So I'm not like a needing to have
like exact moments in the day.
So it works out fine for me.
You just accept the fact that this
is what you're doing right now.
That's what I'm doing.
I've been busy my whole life.
Just different kind of busy.
You more money.
It's more money.
It's more publicity.
It's better,
better busy.
That is a,
you know,
it's a funny thing that people
can really learn from it,
isn't it?
You know,
the,
the attitude that you have
about what you just have to do,
it can really affect the way you feel,
the way your day goes,
the way you interact with everybody.
You can do the same thing and have a
great attitude about it and it really does
like it's a choice.
That's one of the few
choices in life that you get.
You can choose to just fucking this,
just got to deal with it.
This is what it is.
Not being a bitch about it.
Yeah.
I mean the bottom line is everybody's
got to do something during the day.
Some were pissed off about it,
a little things he has to do and some
people love all the shit that they have to
do.
It doesn't matter.
You know?
It's all about how you're interpreting
it and whether you're going to be
positive or negative
about the whole thing.
And
because she is busy,
I say it because I know that a lot of
fighters about problems with a lot of
fighters get real upset when they have
to do a big publicity tours right before
fights,
especially important fights.
I feel like it detracts from training.
And we were talking here about,
you know,
you do in 15 minute runs on the treadmill
and I just fucking jump in the shower.
You just gotta sneak.
It's hard.
Yeah.
That's what it takes to,
you know,
it's just like,
just enough to make sure
that I feel like crap.
Right.
The end of it,
you know,
then that's a,
that's a good worthy workout.
And you could do that.
I mean,
I could do that and probably three
minutes if I need to kick it up to like 12
and then like,
you know,
put it on an incline or do whatever.
I mean,
you can get yourself tired and push
herself in a short amount of time.
That's a crazy workout,
man.
It's really,
it's funny.
Everybody thinks you have to go the the
gym and workout for an hour and a half,
but you know,
you can do some crazy shit on an incline
treadmill and you're done in three
minutes.
Yeah.
I mean you could,
if you're doing it hard enough,
there's all sorts of shit you can do
to get yourself exhausted and just like
mentally tapped like in
a short period of time.
So get us sometimes utilize that.
Yeah.
So when you're on the road,
you just think like,
okay,
whatever I can get in.
I get in.
Do you ever do like hotel workouts?
I've done some hotel workouts,
but it also helps I get folks all over.
I mean really if we needed to,
we could go after this and go get
a role in or something like that.
And I've got guys all over all over the
US and all over the world now where you
know,
if I'm in town I'm like,
Hey,
let's get a workout in.
Hit Mitts,
get a role in sparring.
I mean,
everyone's always down.
Yeah,
that's so true.
It's one of the coolest things about
working for the UFC that I even get to do
that.
Like I got to train.
Like Duke Roof has trained me
a few times and telegraph days.
Train me a few times and
both guys are bad ass.
I'd ask cool dudes.
That's one of the things that a lot of
people don't realize about martial arts
is most of the people that
are good at martial arts,
they went through a lot of shit to
get good develops character and you're
dealing with a majority of people
who are really fucking cool.
You know,
like John Hackleman cool as fuck.
You know what I mean?
So many of these guys,
it Telegraaf take cool as fuck cylinders.
Yeah.
This fucking Real Greg Jackson one
the nicest guys on the planet earth.
Just a bunch of cool
motherfuckers in this game.
It's really amazing.
Very few people realize it.
They don't the the key to
having a bunch of cool people.
It's having a bunch of
people their ego in check.
Okay.
Yeah.
Why,
why is there a reason that
especially a guy like,
I mean you look at Duke Roufus
and you look at Della Garate,
you look at Phil nurse in Jackson,
all these guys and they've been there
like Phil's never broken his hand,
but he's got a lump like a mountain
on his hand while he's been in fights.
And Rufus is a,
from a fitting break,
his hand,
just little,
uh,
compounds over time just built up.
I mean,
these guys have been through wars.
Why nothing to prove.
They know they're bad ass and yeah,
they respect everyone and yeah,
there's the worst aspect of men is men
that aren't sure themselves want to
convince everyone around them instead,
you know,
they want to be,
uh,
the,
the guy walks in the room and everybody
cowers and fear because they're secretly
fear themselves.
Exactly.
Yeah.
It's the weirdest thing in the world when
you see a guy like that get their ass
kicked.
That's right.
You know,
it's real.
Real gangsters don't flex much,
I think they call it.
They don't have to,
they don't run fast.
It's real gangsters don't
have to real gangsters,
whatever fucking distorted word.
And the 20s,
21st century,
it's become something different.
You know,
it's like something's good.
This gangster,
that's all that's all quoted from.
Damn.
It feels good to be a gangster.
Great Song.
One of the best songs that they would
let me come out to other songs and they
will only make you come
out to California kid.
I tried to do it because we
got to talk to Dana and have,
damn,
it feels good to be a gangster.
You come up with some
old school Geto boys.
Going back to Cali.
I was a dad.
Bras to put one.
Two.
Why can't you do on going back to Cali?
Is it because they have to pay?
Is that that it maybe?
No.
Then all about marketing.
I mean that's my,
that's my,
that is my song.
When people hear that going
back to Cali would be the shit.
It would be awesome.
That would be that.
Kelly,
why don't they just mash it up?
Have somebody mash it up for you.
I tried that too.
Dana won't let us.
Goddammit Dana.
We're going to have to talk to him.
That's ridiculous.
Going back to Cali,
it's the shit going back to Cali.
She'll bikini small heels tall.
She said she likes the ocean.
That's a classic.
Why can't you come out to that Dana wide?
What the fuck dude?
When I first started the WC,
I wanted California love and they
would not let me come out to it.
They had me come out to,
I forget what I used to come out too,
but they're like,
ah.
I was like,
I want to come out to California love.
And I always mix it up.
Right.
They wouldn't let me.
They wouldn't let me in.
Then I took a stand,
my first Jens Pulver fight and I told him,
I'm coming out to California left.
Why did they have an argument over what
fucking music they think they know it's
cool.
I'm saying allow me,
is this read?
This was Peter dropping,
bless his heart.
How dare you,
Peter.
He wouldn't let me come out to
California and then it finally come out.
Somebody probably tells him,
right?
I'm sure.
Sure.
But I was like,
look,
let me worry about what's cool for me.
And you guys just fucking
run the cameras and shit.
Well,
it's sort of like become your a party,
your thing.
No,
it's a pretty fucking dope song too.
It actually,
if I had to choose between
which song are better.
I liked that song better,
but it would be cool to mix
it up every once in a while.
It mix it up.
Yeah.
Well I like Rowan bias come
out till like one song,
you know?
I don't know why.
Like Mike Brown,
I like when it comes down to simple man.
I don't know why he just,
he always does.
Like when Matt Hughes
would come out to country,
boy can't survive.
That was part of the fun of it.
You know Joe Benevidez stranglehold.
Fucking love that song.
That's a,
that's a song that Randy came out
too when he fought mark homer.
Yeah.
Joseph was all upset man.
Oh really?
He's like Randy couture.
He jacked on Twitter and
everything and then Mike a he owes,
gives as a crackup.
He made some comments,
he made some comment.
Randy jacket his music.
That's funny.
So fighter can claim the music.
Fortunately Randy Kennedy could
do whatever the hell he wants.
Well not only that,
Randy's 48 so Randy,
like Ted Nugent stranglehold.
That was when Randy was young.
You know what I mean?
But he's had some other songs.
I mean that's fucking Badass jam.
That is.
Especially when you're coming
out too many black belts,
letting it let people know who's boss.
Randy couture.
If he had adopted that strategy
early on in his career,
I think he could have
submitted a lot of guys.
Oh yeah.
Once you started to like really
concentrating on with Neil melanzane on
submissions.
I mean he's such a an expert grappler.
Can we just have to go right to
that from the beginning if he like,
if he embraced like Brazilian Jujitsu,
like right away he would
be a super black belt.
We be ridiculous.
How about,
how about a guy like Mark Coleman?
Malcolm,
dude,
I wrote about this in my book.
Did you and I,
it's called use your head whatever way
you can and it's basically talks about
how I was at a bar in Vegas with Coleman.
His buddies were like,
oh Coleman back in the day
wouldn't headbutts were legal.
Nobody can be Colman
and Colman didn't really say anything,
but his guys were going on and he didn't,
he didn't like this claimant at all.
But it's tough to fuck with that
big dude on top of you head button,
the shit out.
This shit.
That is a real weapon.
Right.
Well how do you feel about headbutts and
elbows to the back of the head when it
strikes the back of the head?
Well,
if somebody's got the,
gotten me in a position where they can
hold me down an elbow to the back of my
head,
fuck,
go for it.
I mean I fucked up.
Right,
right,
right.
You know what I mean?
What you mean?
It's like you get to that point
where a headbutting or an elbowing,
someone in the back of the head is like,
like the position you're in,
you probably gonna get
your ass kicked anyway.
So go ahead and do it.
Yeah.
So it's weird.
We've got a weird rule system.
You know,
it's,
it's kind of vague,
you know,
and then the back of the head,
it's sort of changed.
I had heard it was a Mohawk,
you know,
it was,
it was that you just got to touch the ear,
you have to touch the ear.
Part of it has to be like here,
like some part of it has to touch the ear.
So vague and it's,
you know,
and like situations like Eric Silva,
when he got disqualified in Brazil,
it was like that was bad.
That costs Chad a penalty.
Did it really?
Yeah,
because that ref got yelled at for
doing the Brazilians who wasn't in Mario
Yamasaki Yamasaki who's an awesome,
awesome,
rough,
but he told us in the back
of somebody grabs the cage,
we're deducting appoint period,
you know,
if it stops to take it right then he gets,
he puts himself in that position
doing the bag call where it was like,
I mean,
the guy won the fight.
It was a bad call.
You know,
it's one of those calls that you
should have the power to reverse with,
um,
with
instant replay because it was,
it was clear that the guy was hurt,
that,
you know,
prater was hurt.
He was hurt.
Bad wasn't clear.
You know when you,
when you looked at it like that,
it should have been stopped from
strikes the back of the head.
So then you've got to play it back and
then when you played it back everybody
was like come on.
And it was just like maybe there was one.
They should,
I don't know why they do it.
It's weird when they have like rules,
like they just say,
this is just how we do it.
Like,
and this is how it's written.
Like that's not,
so you have some new technology.
The average person,
the average intelligent person would say,
well let's look at a video so that way
we can be sure this is a career defining
mistake.
Didn't they take that
away from football to,
are they reinstate it?
Cause when I was a kid I thought
there was always an instant replay.
I don't know.
I don't follow football.
Since I got laid actually
you wrestled all throughout high school.
I wrestled all throughout high school.
I played football too.
I was did you really was my first love
really from like third grade on up.
And I think I stopped following
football once I got laid and it was like
Saturday and Sunday was no
longer about watching football.
It was about chicks that almost cost
me my competitive taekwondo career.
When I started getting pussy
it was like a barely showed up.
Wait these girls like me cause
I'm kicking him with Das.
All right,
hold on a second.
Three evaluate.
Yeah I showed up at class wants all Tan
and my instructor's making fun of me.
I'm like what the fuck you been?
He knew what was up right
around the same age.
Pretty girlfriend followed
me everywhere I went.
That's awesome.
That's a,
that's a,
that's a huge distraction for athletes.
It is.
Well it can be Ken Bay.
How about the guy that that gets all
hung up on chicks cause there's like
different kinds of chicks.
There's chicks that'll be like
waiting on you hand and foot.
You don't have to worry
about I'm this and that.
And there's the like the chick
that you have to go watch out.
Cause if you turn your back,
your buddies are going
to be on top of her.
You gotta Watch out.
Those are the ones you got to watch out.
What I've seen guys that like actively
go after chicks like that and it's just
retarded ruins.
You know,
some dude's just love sabotage that.
A lot of it is guys also that are unsure
in their life and are subconsciously
looking for something to distract them
from all the bullshit they really should
be handling,
you know,
about their own life.
So I think it has to do with
their moms could be that too.
Like they're like going after what they,
what they know it.
Huh?
Oh your mom's like crazy and said,
you know,
well that's probably the case cause my
mom was like really nice and like real
easy going so is mine.
And what else you ask
but ask her high school friends.
Really.
Right?
Yeah.
It's a,
it's,
that's it.
That is the grand trap and picks it.
Picking the wrong people
to spend your time.
What the specialty or like a
relationship like you know,
like I was reading about some
guy who killed his girlfriend,
you know,
she broke up with him and he
killed her and I was thinking,
you know what a what a terrible
situation for that girl.
She fucked up and got
like worst case scenario,
one of the biggest idiots
in the fucking world that's
so can handle a breakup.
He has to go back and kill you.
You know what a fucking loser like that,
that it does like loser.
Then you got to look at her too.
I mean like what made her attracted
to the guy that was going to kill her?
I mean it's like probably violence.
I think there's a correlation there too.
Could be,
but it also could be youth,
you know?
I mean I've done a lot of stupid things
when I was young and they don't really
define me.
They just to find that I
didn't know shit at the time.
I mean that's the whole,
the,
the process of life is about,
you know,
learning from fuck ups.
She shouldn't have to get killed because
she had a weird thing for like some
thug life type dude.
Yeah,
I remember.
I mean,
I've seen girls get ruined.
I was from a small town,
it was like Mexicans and cowboys,
you know,
I moved there in the seventh grade and
you'd see like a girl just like take the
wrong path at next.
He knows she's got like a neck tattoo
and like pregnant and like the ninth
grade.
That was it.
That's a cowboy,
right?
No.
Where did you grow up?
I was in Lincoln,
the Lincoln of Lincoln.
Where's Lincoln?
Outskirts of Sacramento.
I moved there in the
seventh grade and like,
you know,
country cruise and there
was like 7,000 people.
Now there's like 40,000.
Wow.
And we get a lot with a lot of crap,
like jumping cars out in the country.
We got in trouble one time,
uh,
we had off campus lunch and so we'd have,
you know,
in the springtime season's over
and all that kind of stuff.
We'd be out in the country driving
around drinking beers on the roof in like
doing crazy stuff.
And somebody called in the school and,
uh,
it was like,
we saw you Ryan,
we'll Craig or Jim Cannon on the,
on the roof of the car drinking
beers and this and that.
And I go back and,
and I had their principal
loved us and she's like,
we had reports that you're
drinking beers sitting on the roof.
And like,
we were on the roof and we
were not drinking beers.
And she's like,
that's what I told him.
You guys wouldn't be doing that
free and clear.
7,000 people.
What is that like?
That's gotta be weird
growing up in a really small,
that's pretty small,
right?
Yeah.
That's very funny.
You know everybody,
right?
Everybody know everybody.
Oh,
of course too.
That's weird.
I don't know anybody in my neighborhood.
You know what though?
It's good though.
I mean,
that's better.
I think it's good.
I mean,
everybody knows,
you know,
you can't be a slime
ball if you're slamming.
Everybody knows you're slimeball.
It's a real community.
It's a community and uh,
you're,
you're forced to have a conscience.
That's actually a interesting,
I always trust chicks from,
from New York or New Jersey.
Really?
Not Really,
really?
No.
Only small town girls.
Not only small town but you prefer,
I would say I,
I'm pretty good judge of character but I
feel like over there like the girls are
dealing with guys that are like that are
a different level like the guys like on
on Jersey shore a little bit,
you know what I mean?
So they have to kind of like adapt and
become like hard and like a mild version
of that,
which is like a full on version of
like a player out in California.
Okay.
Yeah.
The the,
the kind of aggression that you have
to deal with on the east coast is very
different.
There's a lot of douchey dude's
yeah,
like blatantly call want to take you out,
girl.
I've heard some like funny stories
and and stuff where guys are like,
yeah,
all right.
I grew up with those idiots.
You know,
east coast is a different vibe,
man.
It's totally different.
They're hardened.
I got my mom and my dad
calling me right now.
Good problem and bad problem to have.
It's like,
okay guys,
parents,
uh,
there,
there were um,
Kinda hippie is out of the deal.
Yeah.
Back in the day,
you know,
there,
well I was,
I made the 70s,
1979 and my parents were
out and I live Vista,
California,
which is like the college town
right next to Santa Barbara.
And they weren't going to college.
They were just chilling,
you know,
my dad was,
working odd jobs and,
and they actually met at
a restaurant and stuff,
but they're like part of a hippie
Christian commune and Oh good.
So hippie Christian College.
How'd they work that out?
I Dunno.
I was barely,
yeah,
we left.
It was like for the communes always
seemed like a great idea until some dude
starts fucking everybody's white,
you know,
it's always that.
It's always starts out with a great idea.
We're going to form our home
communities is going to be beautiful
movie right now.
What's the movie that's out right now?
I don't know which,
it's hilarious though.
It's about like the calming,
like they stop and they're going to like
get married and they like car breaks
down and they'd pull into this car.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Who the fuck is in there
as a gen for Anson?
Tommy,
you remember?
Oh my God.
We're talking about
Jennifer Aniston movie.
Yes.
We might be a couple of quarters.
The legal excitedly about Jennifer Harris.
Is there anybody that nailed the females
genre more than Jennifer Aniston?
Lock that shit down.
If a girl tells me she wants to take
you to a Jennifer Aniston movies,
go,
Oh fuck.
You know.
If someone says like,
you're going to go to
a Meryl Streep movie,
that check could be anything.
Do you ever meet her Joe?
Meryl Streep?
No.
I saw her once in real life.
She had a great character.
She's right there.
I was like as close as you are to
me and Courtney Cox was there too,
where you're looking through a window.
No,
we,
when we were on it,
when I was on NBC,
I was on the news radio and news radio
was like the redheaded stepchild of NBC.
They didn't get any promotion at
all until after it was canceled.
When it was canceled,
then it became popular.
It was really weird,
like through DVD sales and through,
um,
people watching it,
like on late night TV.
But we would go to these things where
you would have all the publicity things.
Nobody wanted to talk to us,
especially me.
Nobody gave a fuck about me.
I'm on the Sitcom.
It's barely hanging on.
Like at one point in time,
uh,
my friend Joe was one of the writers
would write down on his shirt or no,
I'm sorry.
Lou Lou Morton.
I don't know why I called him Joe.
Confusing the guys.
Lou Martin used to write down his shirt.
What the number was that
we were ranked on TV.
He came in one day and said,
[inaudible] 84 we were like,
fucking 84 were,
you know,
friends was
number one.
We were 84.
The president of NBC was on.
I like,
what's that Fez show that's off?
Or in fact,
Ron in Fez.
Yeah,
I think it was Ron and fast.
And he was talking about
after Phil died were,
uh,
um,
Andy wanted more money.
Yeah.
Did you hear the whole story?
I've ever brought it up
cause it's a terrible story.
President brought it up,
I'm sure.
Well,
you know what I,
you know,
you know Andy,
Andy's Andy,
he's fucking crazy.
But the thing that he said,
yeah,
I was on second with him.
That guy is nuts.
What happened with you and him?
He Cam,
is he openly gay?
I don't know.
That's a secret.
Oh No.
Oh,
he's on some absurd stuff to me.
One time I met him and the other time,
the,
for the first time I met him,
I was at a,
at a hotel downtown in La.
Get you to talk like right into here.
Yeah,
it'd be a lot louder.
Hello?
We can
both hear each of the grade,
but on the recording
people get pissed at me.
It was like we were there at,
uh,
at a,
just a little bar in,
in this hotel.
And I'm with my manager
and just kicking it.
He starts,
it's like coming on to me like hard.
And then he's like,
he's like,
I'm like,
like saying stuff.
I thought he was joking and
he says,
how old are you?
And I was like,
27.
He's like,
you're too fucking all.
Like,
I'm like,
I'm like this and that.
And he's like,
I just like basically tick off.
Then the second time I met him,
he was with a band.
Does he have a band or something
or you have a band at the,
uh,
at the hard rock and I bought and I
was the elevator and his buddies like,
Oh man,
we're big fans.
Some band there with,
I forget what band it was.
And they're like,
come in and meet,
meet the rest of the band.
And he's in there and he's shit faced any,
like,
starts chasing me around.
He's like taking a Piss,
like stomach rise,
like the middle of the
day and he's wasted.
He's like taking a piss and he like
comes out Raftery he's done taking a piss
and he like chased me around the room
and like coming here and then I'll fuck
her,
I'm going to this and that and I'm like,
jump.
I'm like,
Whoa,
like pants fall down.
I'm like,
what's going on with this guy?
I just want to be lying down in there.
And it was like,
but he's got kids.
He's got a bunch of kids.
Okay,
well I don't know if that was a secret,
but oh,
he's crazy.
I've worked with that guy for
five years and he's always like,
you bang if you were an asshole to me.
No,
never banged them.
We've got an inappropriate for the story.
I talked to him the other
night and I was saying like,
I was like,
man,
I want you to come back on so bad,
but I don't know you
guys fuck out of here.
What's wrong with you?
He's such a nice,
what's wrong with you dude?
He's so awesome.
You just see what he said.
Did you just hear what you say
with that for five days?
This guy,
he doesn't want it.
He never wants to believe that anything.
Sam,
he's like,
you are an asshole to me.
Do you know what you were like,
you crazy.
Fuck.
He knocked on my door in my room
and he goes open a Daria Craig.
I was getting changed.
I open up the door and he's like,
you're in that fucking aren't you?
And he had his dick out.
He was like,
I talked about this before,
but what's fucked up about it
was he didn't even have the,
fucking,
didn't even,
didn't even get hard first
to get hard.
Not even having to do this is very
hard.
I can understand why he was gone so crazy.
He's a talented motherfucker.
He was.
He is is a really,
he
really funny guy.
But he's crazy.
He doesn't mean to be a bad guy,
but he doesn't give a fuck.
Which is interesting because
most people do give a fuck.
So there's that element of it.
I mean,
there's a couple of people in this world
that really don't give a fuck and are
entertaining,
you know?
And he's definitely,
I really loved that level.
I mean,
it's just,
it's just too much work,
you know?
I wish him the best,
but it's just,
I don't,
you know,
the,
the one podcast we have the most plenty.
When he started talking about
how attracted he was to me,
I was so attracted to you anyway.
Oh,
top five podcasts of all time.
Yeah,
because you're a sick fuck.
You got a problem.
The chemistry between you two is amazing.
He means that it's real amazing
being around a crazy person.
Yeah.
But somebody that you know and you know
that he's not going to go crazy on you.
When I say crazy,
I mean,
like I said,
he,
I would still,
you know,
somebody came up with a Sitcom and
it was going to be me and Andy Dick.
I would still have to consider it.
That'd be the best like bosom buddies.
I wouldn't,
I don't want to ever do
a sit calm again though.
I don't know.
It's,
it's,
it's hard to get a guy like that a gig
unfortunately because he's made a few
mistakes by the way.
Joe,
someone up or something?
I don't think so.
I think he just pulled out his dick on
numerous occasions that Dr com videos on
Youtube.
By the way,
everyone download that guide.
It's on there.
It's from,
it seems like it's from
another country from it.
They played the episode overseas.
Any episode.
That's ridiculous.
It's on the Internet.
Yeah,
that's it.
Yeah.
Wow.
Those silly bitches,
they got so greedy.
They figured we'll just sell this episode
to like Denmark or something and not
aired in America.
Well in other countries there's no
problem with that because they drink that
shit.
Well that's where the thing
about fear factor is you have to,
someone has to eat it in some other
part of the world for us to serve it.
So like when people in New Zealand and
started drinking shots of horse calm,
they would sell it at bars like as a,
as a goof,
like you have a cup of [inaudible] and
then you'd get Randy like let's have a
fucking hot as a bad New Zealand accent.
And it was also a horse urine.
You never said
it was actually cow urine that I never
said donkey urine because I would have to
tell the truth.
And it wasn't dark urine,
but it was donkey comp
was cow and donkey Kong.
Wow.
Who is the test dummy for that?
He's like,
wow,
that's really crazy.
We had some people that work for him.
He's under an account is working it.
We had some people that
work for us that uh,
had to actually do it as
well as the contestants.
You know,
we got to get people to test
it to see if it was possible.
So we have PA's and you know,
they would only get $100 to drink,
like 24 ounces a donkey come.
And I had more money on them,
so I gave them a few hundred bucks out
of my own pocket for having to do it.
But I was just like,
this is the craziest fucking
thing I've ever seen.
I had a your harsh,
yeah,
Andrea Summers,
you know,
that is a little blond.
Diego,
her and her boyfriend and if he'd be,
how'd they do?
How well do you do?
She said she was 15
seconds away from winning.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Why can't I remember?
He has something to do with pot.
You think Alpha brain or pot?
I'll know.
You know there's too many
people that I did 148 episodes.
Holy Shit.
There's too many people 148
episodes most of the time.
Most of the time it was a,
it was like six,
eight people.
You'd have to remember every
week four you'd get down to four,
you know,
it's like,
and then the next week it
would be a whole new people.
And I just,
my memory bank would just a race,
there's a thing called Dunbar's number.
Oh,
there it is.
There's a thing called Dunbar's
number and a what Dunbar's number is.
Um,
it's uh,
looking at what does that language,
I said
we probably shouldn't play
this dude because this is a,
they're going to,
people are going to get
sued for that or something.
I assume that was the donkey come episode.
Yeah.
Just see the,
like the size of the bucket
that's in front of them.
We could show.
I'll show it to you if
you want to watch it.
And it is on TV.
I mean it is on the Internet.
It's pretty intense.
Those twins,
it doesn't belong.
There were twins and there was a Brunette
twins and then two dudes that were
twins.
It was a twins episode.
That's awesome.
How many ounces of that 127 oh by the way,
it's on more than one.
Um,
oh yeah.
Cause he had one.
It was on Twitter that
I saw her earlier to.
It's on a bunch of different formats now.
I knew it would come out eventually,
but man,
it's,
Chris twins are awesome.
Yeah,
they were very hot.
All of them are.
It's just disturbing.
I would love to have,
when I have kids have twin boys,
I would hate to have twin girls.
Yeah,
I know.
Everywhere they go,
someone thinking about fucking them.
And you don't even have to be that hot.
Yeah,
let's not,
let's not have this on think folks.
If they want to find it,
it's out there.
Can we just do like just flashed it
right when they're drinking the whites?
No,
no,
no.
I just don't think we should.
I don't know what the legal status of all
this stuff is and I don't know what my
position is and
don't just cause I don't
know what my position is.
I that might be illegal for me to do.
I might get sued or something.
The uh,
the show was because of that,
which it was a good thing or the
shows canceled because of that.
Yeah,
because the people,
the people that have drink dog,
I mean essentially they had a real hard
time finding advertisers in the first
place and then after this got on Tmz,
they will like get the fuck out of here.
They were pretty convinced it was
going to be brought back before that.
Well now with this Internet video leak,
maybe it will be,
maybe will become their,
you know what,
man,
I'm happy it's done.
I wouldn't do it again.
I did it.
I'm done.
It was,
it's,
it's an actual job that
you said last time I did,
but yeah.
But this time,
this time I'm totally
serious because I did try it.
I took six years off.
We'll try it again and not really anyway,
back to you.
And you're right.
Let's talk about you man.
Fucking fuck me.
Um,
tell me more about this.
A hippie childhood cause you like grew
up with like holistic medicine and apple
cider vinegar,
that kind of Shit.
Yeah.
Well starting starting out was
basically in the Hippie commune,
you know,
like,
I love this.
It was like,
you know,
free spirited Christian,
like everyone,
like,
you know,
you go to church and it's like people
like reaching up to the sky and like
people crying and stuff like that.
But uh,
so you can work really well.
That must have been really true.
Has it's called new hope,
new hope church or whatever it was,
didn't last.
No,
I mean that my family and
my dad's side is first,
my dad's first generation American
from Holland and they're really,
really strong Christians
on the dad's side.
And my mom's side is not so much,
you know,
my,
it's like not,
not,
not anything like that.
So I think it was like
a mixture of the two.
My Dad,
you know,
it was like,
grew up,
he's the first guy,
first guy from his
family to be in America.
And like in the 70s it was kind of like a,
a wild child and stuff like that.
And then like born again Christian
after certain amount of time.
So they spent like the early parts of my
childhood were in that environment and
it kind of lasted,
some of the stuff lasted,
you know,
throughout my life.
But it was,
my parents got divorced
when I was in kindergarten,
so that was like,
then I went back to one side,
kind of happened at once.
I had really not,
you know.
Wow.
That must have been a,
an interesting childhood to go from that.
How do you go from that to being
a mixed martial arts fighter?
Uh,
well the thing is about the mentality
is just basically encouraging you to do
whatever the heck you want.
You know?
And,
and my parents aren't like,
you know,
never had any mapped out.
It was always like,
my dad's like super proud of
anything that we ever had done.
And my mom's like,
you know,
always just pushing you to be,
uh,
you know,
the best at whatever you do.
So this is just what I was drawn to.
I always used to watch the boxing.
All my favorite movies
were a karate movies and,
and you know,
all that kind of stuff.
And,
and how many kids grew up with you?
It was my brother and my little sister.
My little sister is 13 when she was born.
So it was just me and my brother.
Really.
She was 13 when,
who was born?
My brother,
my sister was born when I
was 13 and I swapped it.
Yeah.
So what do they do now?
My brother lives in
Sacramento and actually
he's,
he's an interesting case.
He actually went to college on a
scholarship and had like a complete mental
breakdown at the age of 21.
Whoa.
Yeah.
So he's never really been the same.
It's,
it's kind of a,
I actually,
my book,
I talk about it like,
uh,
like the whole effect that had on
all of our lives and everything.
But,
um,
he went away on a scholarship,
was like the captain of the football team,
captain of the wrestling team,
went away to a Christian school,
got recruited by this church
called International Church
of Christ and was like
trying to live this perfect life,
like not thinking about sex.
He was eating less,
sleeping less.
He was getting like 25% of his money that
he's working at Nordstrom at a cafe at
Nordstrom at the time.
And like giving his money
away and had like a breakdown.
Man,
we don't really know
exactly what happened,
but he's a,
he works with my,
with my family when he can,
so like that.
But it's been kind of an uphill,
uphill battle for us.
How many years ago was this?
14 years ago or Whoa,
I,
senior year in high school.
Jesus Christ.
So he was as bad motherfucker
and then it blew a fuse.
Like he hit the red line
too hard too many times.
Yeah.
We don't know
exactly what happened.
I mean,
we got a call and uh,
we got a call from his boss at work or
at Nordstrom and then a family that he
was staying with.
We checked in and they said the,
yeah,
he's been,
uh,
he's lost lot of weight.
He was like 165 pounds in high school,
wrestling 165 pounds.
He was like 130,
120 530 pounds had been like,
wasn't smiling was like washing his hands,
obsessive Lee and my mom
and my stepdad and my,
my pop and,
and his wife all jumped in a car on New
Year's Day in 1998 and drove to La and,
and brought him home.
Wow.
Yeah,
it's been a crazy,
if you read,
if you read the chapter is a chapter out
of my book that talks about just life's
hiccups and the uncontrollable stuff.
And it was,
it was pretty crazy man.
Also some good stories
cause after 13 years,
you know,
it is what it is and you just kind
of deal with what life gives you.
And he's a funny
Mofo.
He's funny.
I mean he's still really
intelligent risks.
Unpredictable and like,
you know,
like we've been so easy.
A different guy.
Oh yeah.
100%.
So like saw a fuse blew and your brother's
gone and there's a new guy there now.
Pretty much.
Yeah.
And uh,
you know,
it's,
it's been a trip man.
And my little sister is 13 one when I was
13 when she was born and my brother is
two and a half years older than I am,
so she's never really,
she's never really remembered
him as I grew up with him,
you know what I mean?
Is My older brother and everything else
has been like a modified version of
that.
And I mean,
he goes up and has some
times and then has some,
some bad times too,
but it's definitely interesting.
I did.
And there's nothing they can do about
something like that when it's not like is
it a counseling issue or is it physical
aspect of the [inaudible] Stan,
my mom doesn't like to
call it schizophrenia,
but that's basically the,
uh,
the matrix of what what's going on is
just anything that they deem is like,
don't know what it is they
throw in that category.
And he definitely has different
signs throughout time of,
of having that kind of,
you know,
schizophrenia behaviors.
So it's just unpredictability man.
It's crazy.
You live a wild,
crazy fucking life.
You're a professional cage fighter.
Do you ever wonder like,
you know,
I know that just from,
obviously I've never,
I never fought in MMA,
but I know from seeing all the fucking
championship fights that I've seen,
all the high pressure
situations that I've seen,
like the toll that it must have on your
psyche for a lot of dudes is pretty
fucking incredible.
Do you ever like see your brother and go,
you know,
this,
is this possible that
this could happen to me?
Could I blow a fuse too?
Um,
it is possible for anybody.
You didn't think so.
Oh yeah.
Yeah,
definitely.
I mean,
I think,
uh,
do you worry about it?
No,
no,
no.
You can't walk around worried
about life in general.
He never leave the room.
If I had a sister that was
a cuckoo for cocoa puffs,
I'll go,
God damn,
I might be fucking crazy too.
I might be in denial,
you know,
I might just be at
least you're successful.
Crazy.
You know what I mean?
Who knows.
But well,
maybe your brother should get into comedy.
It sounds like every comedian.
Irresponsible.
Hilarious.
He's definitely has his moments lost
his shit because work was too fucking
crazy.
That sounds like a comedian man.
And you said he's funny.
He is that dude in the standup comedy.
You're in northern California
and plenty of places to do it.
You'd have to beat my bro.
I mean there's,
there's a ease.
Ease,
an interesting cat man.
Yeah.
And we all love him.
And uh,
I dunno if he could,
he could definitely.
Uh,
he could definitely have a couple moments.
I'm going to pull up some
videos of him on the phone,
actually.
Does he work?
He does works periodically,
but it's just when he can't,
cause it's just unpredictable.
There's times where he'll go like a
whole year where things are straight for
him,
too much stimulus or happen
or even sometimes a year.
And he just kind of had,
so it's almost like he
really did red line.
His brain.
Yeah.
Wow.
And we don't know what happened.
I mean,
we don't,
as far as
you know,
when you,
when you see guys like
the highest level of any,
any sport,
especially when it comes to like,
um,
wrestling or anything where it's like
super ultra competitive and you hear
stories of a guy like a Dan Gable,
you know,
you hear stories about a guy
who he was a little crazy.
Fucking gay was crazy.
Yeah.
I mean that guy paid the
price for it physically too.
Like today he's got hip replacements
and his knees are shot and you know,
yeah,
for sure.
You have you ever read up on him?
He know about his sister and
all that kind of horrible,
she was murdered,
murdered by her neighbor,
raped and murdered and stuff like that.
And to heat.
That was what drove him.
He was a demon.
That guy was possessed.
You ever see those videos
of him when he was younger?
I mean,
we'll talk about it,
you know,
and like she's fucking terrifying.
I was terrified.
I wrestle.
I wrestled at Uc Davis and we spent,
uh,
you know,
we had a couple of different tournaments
where an Iowa and we went to Iowa.
He was retired from coaching
and wasn't competing.
Just old Dan Gable and we're in the room
working out and he's in there in a full
sweat suit with the hood up and he's
drilling double legs on this dummy against
the wall,
just drilling.
Bam,
Bam.
He gets on the bike and he's
like just pushing himself on the,
on the,
on the stationary bike
and just going crazy.
No one else's in the room.
It's just him.
The guy's just like,
he's on it.
Jesus Christ.
He's never letting it go.
However,
I think trilon double legs.
How old was he?
Like 60 yeah.
At least Jesus Christ's 60 year
old dudes shooting doubles,
drilling them with sweatsuits on
figure.
If you get,
you're in a,
in a repetition.
I'm the same way.
If I'm,
if I'm not working out
for a period of time,
it just doesn't feel right.
You know what I mean?
It feels weird.
It's probably like some people were
smoking cigarettes or you know,
whatever else.
The,
the routine is become like you don't
feel yourself unless you're like putting
your body feel a little something.
And I'll be the same way.
I don't feel balanced.
I don't trust myself if
I don't work out hard,
if I,
if I work out hard,
I feel like my brain is able to,
to react to things on an even field.
Whereas if I'm stressed,
like if I haven't worked out in
a couple of days and I'm all,
it's all built up,
you got think you can over react to
things because your brain is looking for
some fucking something to see.
I got to get rid of this
pressure that's been building up.
Yeah.
It's weird.
It's weird the way,
uh,
I mean it's just routine.
You know,
it's like,
it's like a,
it's like an OCD type,
but I'm not by any,
any means like an OCD type of person.
I like,
like I said,
I don't,
I'm not great at structure and I'm good.
I'm good at sticking to a game plan,
but like I could sleep in
the car and this car seat,
I could sleep on the floor and I don't
need to like go through a routine,
but some people like need to have
the little things that they do right.
They don't feel right in my,
I think is just about a certain amount
of energy that I have to exert to the day
or else I can't sleep.
Right.
That's interesting.
Do you think that that is a routine
thing or do you think that your body just
requires that because
you're mean you're your,
your body is essentially a race car?
Yeah,
I think my body requires,
I mean I think I have a certain amount
of energy that I needed to get out.
If I get myself thinking about
something too late in the,
in the,
in the night or you know,
like watch sparring or
watch something on my,
the in a fight,
I'm like amped up and ready.
Right.
That's a problem.
Right?
You have to time that shit out.
Yeah.
You got a time and I'm,
I've been blowing it,
especially with time in Vegas.
It's like I just found myself
not getting enough sleep,
but you know,
it's like not wanting to go to bed
but having to get up in the morning.
Do you ever sleep in
the hyperbaric chamber?
I know you've used it several times and
it's one of the things I really wanted
to ask you about,
cause I'm kind of fascinated by it.
The results of the hyperbaric
chamber are pretty spectacular.
Yeah.
They're crazy.
And I,
I've,
I've gone in there and
slept a couple of times,
but it's only,
you know,
you only want to do it a
certain amount of time.
It certain amount of,
uh,
length of time,
you know,
it's like an hour and a half for this
certain time sheet kind of treatment.
It's an hour for,
uh,
other types of treatments is dangerous.
It's not dangerous.
But,
uh,
I mean,
I think it,
it's,
it's something that can,
can he mess with you a little bit?
Like when you're doing
the hyperbaric chamber,
nice face.
He meant,
I'm thinking about trying it and now,
but,
uh,
when they do the change of,
of whatever the pressures in there,
it feels like you're going
up and down in a plane.
They can feel your ears like clicking and
stuff like that and you blow them out.
And when they bring
the pressure back down,
you can feel them popping
and stuff like that also.
So,
I mean,
you can feel something's happening.
But the trippiest thing about
the hyperbaric chamber was,
you know,
I started going in,
when I broke my hands against Brown,
I broke my right hand and then I
dislocated my thumb on the left.
And so that was a crazy fight and
the really impressive fight on your,
on your behalf because you broke
your hand in the first round,
you know,
and you went back and you're like,
a broke my fucking head.
And then you're like,
oh,
they're both shot.
And then you're like,
all right,
well it's elbows and kicks.
We'll just do this.
But for three fucking rounds hard.
Well,
you broken the both of them in the first,
I broke the,
the,
the first one in the first round,
so four rounds of that.
And then the third round I dislocated my
oh wow.
And a championship fight and you know,
and you fighting,
you know,
the first guy to take your
title in this crazy fight.
Yeah.
And it was uphill.
Wait too,
because they didn't have 35
when 35 when you decided
to drop down to 35 you,
this is like your home now.
You don't,
you don't feel like,
I'm like,
you know,
at 135 pounds,
this is like the perfect amount of weight.
You Cut.
Perfect.
You're,
you're physically big as big
as anybody in the division.
Yeah.
That's,
that's the thing with 40 fives.
I mean,
people don't understand.
It's like we've got a lot
of new people in the sport.
They don't understand the history of it.
They don't understand that.
When I first started fighting,
I was fighting the Indian casinos.
There was no sanctioning body.
I was wearing shoes.
You can need people in the head.
I saw you fighting one of those.
I saw you fighting the king of the
cage and a casino Indian casinos then
and then you know,
there was no opportunity
for me to find 135 pounds.
I would have,
I was only 148 when I first
started fighting and I was
fighting one 55 and then
I,
I made a stand and said I'm going to
fight at one 45 but that was like making a
stand to do that.
And I became a world champion
up there and you know,
after that it was like I was good enough
to be right there for another title
shot.
I was,
I was able to beat the next contenders
and be competitive enough to get those
out of shots and I'm never
going to turn that down.
I could gone to 35 is a long time ago,
but I was like,
I'm not missing opportunities.
I want to fight Jose Aldo own a fight.
Mike Brown.
I want to say,
you know these guys,
even though they're bigger than I am,
how much bigger was all done than you?
I talked to him.
He said he tries to stay right under
one 70 and I'm about one 54 wow.
That's a lot of fucking way.
We'd one 66 in the ring in the ring
and I would want about one 53 when did
before my phone's big dude.
He's,
he's smaller now though.
He said,
was it harder for him to make that cut?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
So you get older,
it's harder and harder
to dehydrate yourself,
right?
Yeah.
What is the,
what do you,
what are you cutting to get to 35?
Uh,
I'm cutting about 21 pounds.
Jesus Christ.
And when you're,
you know,
when you're talking
about 135 pound result,
you know,
that's,
that's a large percentage.
That's not like a 265 pounder.
Cotton,
20 pounds.
That's a lot.
You know,
Brock Lesnar cut 20 pounds to make to 65.
That's a lot.
But look at the size of that motherfucker
and then look at the size of you.
So you're cutting your dehydrate
nice shit out of yourself.
Yeah,
I mean well I've got it down to a
science because I work out so much.
My weight fluctuates like you know,
five to eight pounds in a day anyways.
Like depending on what I've had to eat
and what my workouts are like and stuff
like that.
So I swing like that like drastically.
Anyways.
So it's just about tricking your body,
you know,
cause it's like how much
sodium you have in your body,
how many electrolytes and stuff like that.
What is it going on Day
Jessica and your stomach.
So if you like treat yourself like a
race car when it comes to the training
thing and once you're down to wait,
you can really like gear
up just for workout,
go on to empty and then either go back
up from there or go back down from there.
And that's where the tricky part gets.
And that's where I've been doing it
for a long time and I have an advantage
because I know my body,
you know,
and it's am I put on 17 pounds
after weighing 13 hours?
It what percentage of your
body is that at 135 pounds.
I'm an idiot.
You got to do tell Tom
even ask Brian to do it.
He looked at me.
I'm going to have my good
Vietnamese American buddy over here.
Statistics.
Tami,
please.
Then I'm roles.
It's like a massive amount of body weight.
Yeah,
it's,
I mean the,
I put too much on the ever done now
over logical did the first time.
Yeah.
The first time I did I put too much weight
on and then I didn't eat much during
the,
the hours before the fight and it's like
woke up and I was like bloated and I
was like,
all right.
I didn't eat,
but luckily like an hour before I went on,
I started to feel normal again.
That was against music.
Gawky wow.
How Wa,
how much of a pain in the ass is that?
That whole process of rehydrating
yourself and trying to feel healthy again
because I would imagine that when you
cut 21 pounds,
like when you're on the scale that day,
you must feel fucking terrible.
Yes,
it's a correct.
I've seen guys wear,
they look like they're ready to die.
Luder
well,
I stopped and I drink that
coconut before anything else.
I'm like,
you need nothing else matters.
I'm going to get this.
He's a lecturer.
Lights in this stuff in my body now
you're barely hanging on.
Right.
It's so crazy.
It's like an event in
and of itself though.
The weight cut.
I was there when Travis Luder miss
weighed against Anderson Silva.
I have never seen a dude
look closer to death.
Travis.
His lips were chapped.
All the water,
the moisture,
it's sucked out of his lips.
His whole body was completely dehydrated
and he wasn't even walking towards the
scale.
This is after he had missed the weight
and he was coming back to try to turn it
to try to make it and he shuffling.
He couldn't even walk you a shuffling.
His face was sunken in and then he quit.
He said,
I can't do it.
I can't do,
I'm done.
This is all I can lose their life.
You have,
you have another hour,
you have another hour if you'd
like to try to lose the weight.
He's like,
I can't do it.
Yeah.
We had one of our guys in
Brazil did that and he,
he uh,
Eddie hoke from Alaska and uh,
he got down to like less
than half a pound over.
But that half nine I was in the,
I was in the sauna in the workout
room with him for like seven hours.
He like getting in,
getting out and I thought you give
him a big pep talk about like,
he was like moping around like shadowbox.
I'm like,
look dude,
you got to hit a mental switch.
He was three pounds over doing this.
I said,
you got to hit a mental
switch now and start moving.
You can't be sitting in the sauna.
You can't be moping around it here.
Like if you want to lose this weight,
you got to do it.
And then,
so that was a push to get them
to lose that last three pounds.
And he got down to a little bit over a
half and it was like nothing was coming
off.
You can no spit coming out.
Oh,
who's this crazy?
That is so scary,
man.
It's so scary that you're basically
bringing yourself on the door of death and
then you got to have a cage fight 24 hour,
27 hours later.
I feel like,
I feel like it's not,
it's not that bad for me.
I I could 21 pounds from
where I'm like heavy,
like Super Janky.
But when I'm in your leanest
prime winter in shape,
when I'm,
when I'm trying to watch my weight and
keep my weight within within like a
striking range,
I'm about one 5,152 and 53 maybe and
then back down to like 48 to 53 you know,
so that's what,
so at 48 the lowest for 13 off.
Yeah,
it's 13 off.
And then from there there's the cut and I,
and I'm like real smart
about sodium intake and,
and things like that.
I'll have like I won't drink water like
a lot of guys do this whole water flush
thing,
I don't do the waterflood I do because
a pound of water was the same amount of
as a pound of Gatorade or or coconut
water or a Kombucha or something like that
and you're getting stuff out of that.
So if I'm going to drink a pound of fluid,
I'm going to have something
positive come out of that.
Some energy in something
that that gives my body,
you know,
something to work with.
That's very interesting.
So you don't drink a lot of water,
you drank water and all
this other stuff as well?
I drink,
yeah.
I drink fluids with purpose and
that helps me get the most out of,
have a little bit of energy.
I feel good when I'm,
when I'm cutting weight all the
way until like the day of the,
the actual way in.
And then it's like,
okay,
the last four pounds really sucks,
but it's like it comes off and then I
feel fine right afterwards as soon as they
get something back into me.
But it's really knowing how
to manipulate your body.
Do you use the same principles?
I mean there's,
there's something going on with this
where guys drink a massive amount of water
up until,
you know,
is it,
is it the same principle that you use
just with Kombucha and coconut water and
all that stuff?
You drink massive amount of fluid.
I wouldn't say that.
So,
so it's like this,
you can get dehydrated.
For me,
they're having too much
sodium or not enough sodium,
right?
So if you have not enough sodium,
you get dehydrated.
As much fluid as you have,
your body's not going to retain any yet.
It was like the osmosis where,
you know,
water will filtrate and go to your body
wherever the sodium electrolytes and
wherever it needs to fill in.
You don't have any of that.
There's nothing drawn.
The water in your body will
just go straight through you.
So I kind of go with that.
Like,
I'll cut down on sodium quite a bit,
but I'll have like sugars.
I'll have like a,
like some sort of chill mixes that I
make myself with like black licorice,
uh,
ginger snaps.
I'll have,
uh,
like a bunch of like whole
nuts and stuff like that.
CAROB chips.
So there's like sugar in there,
but there's also like some
protein and some fiber.
And then I'll have coconut water and
coconut meat from the inside of the baby
coconuts.
And then I'll have like a
little piece of fish or um,
like smoked salmon,
something to get a
little bit of sodium in.
Yeah.
And then,
and then,
uh,
you know,
whatever I drink fluid wise,
it's like a Kombucha is good
for your digestive tract.
It's good.
Like helps you break food
down and keeps things.
Probiotic,
probiotic.
It same with yogurt.
So I'll have like that kind of stuff.
And then egg whites in egg whites,
make sure your body doesn't break down
muscle and you're getting all the rest of
stuff to run everything through you.
And it's kind of like your body's not
taking up any of the fluids that you're
putting in.
It's just taking what it needs and
then you're going to go lose it again.
And then you can either
go up or down from there.
Is that your standard diet?
The,
when you get down to like a certain
point way cutting the hell this is,
this is all you eat.
Yeah,
pretty much.
And I'll mix it up.
You know,
it,
my diet isn't very,
very,
very a ton from when I am
in him not cutting weight.
I just like eat more or less.
And then like consider the
sodium thing quite a bit,
which is like a trip.
That's gotta be a weird
fucking dance isn't it?
Yeah it is.
But when you know your body,
I mean I've done this since,
uh,
I mean I remember cutting
weight in the eighth grade,
didn't know what the heck I was doing
and then I didn't cut weight my freshman
or sophomore year and then junior and
senior year and then all through college.
Is there a way to cut it out of,
of the sport or is it just
a part of sport forever?
You could have,
you could have like a two hour weigh in,
but,
but dudes would still try.
Right.
What had happened,
and this is what happened
in college with me,
is you start out doing a real strict diet
and cutting weight and then you've got
a season where it's like,
uh,
six months out of the year where
you're cutting this weight.
And what happens is you just start
losing muscle and you downsize your,
your body anyways.
So this is better because athletes
are doing it two to three,
maybe four times a year.
And you can just train just specifically
for that fight and then you kit to
maintain your muscle,
your muscle mass and things like that.
Cause you can bring it right back.
But what happens in a long season,
or like if people need to downsize
and compete within a two hour period,
those is downsize their muscle.
So it'd be like the same thing.
So dues was still lose weight anywhere,
did lose weight,
but to be over a more dramatic time.
Um,
and I mean there's certainly that will,
yeah,
they are.
They're trying to get people to
weigh in right before they compete.
The one deals I think does that right?
Yeah.
They weigh in right before
that's not the head trauma.
The thing about striking that makes it
dangerous is a head trauma was on fluid
in the brain.
That's a,
none of the deaths that have occurred in
boxing have occurred in the heavyweight
division.
They've all a occurred in
light of weight divisions.
Really?
Yeah.
And the idea is that those guys were
all cutting weight and when they,
uh,
the guys that are getting hurt,
like Gerald Mcclellan,
well,
he's a famous wake cutter,
used to cut a lot of weight,
you know,
that,
that plays a part that's
not the only factor,
but it,
uh,
that it plays a part.
I actually went to a speech to the doctor
in Sacramento gave about that and he,
he had me as a guest to
listen to everything and,
and it makes sense.
Yeah.
I mean your body is held in place by,
but your brain is held in place by a
bunch of fluid and if you're losing a big
percentage of your fluid from your body,
some of it's probably
coming from your head.
Do you replenish with ivs?
Uh,
I do.
Yeah,
you have to a bag in half.
That's what's happened the
first time I made 35 uh,
I,
I did too much of the ivy
had like almost two bags.
It is too much now.
I do like a bag and like a quarter.
What a crazy process man.
It's pharmacy.
It's a totally different thing.
Concentrate on while you're
concentrating on a professional cage.
Fight against a trained killer
dude.
It's nuts.
But you know what,
it's,
it's to stay competitive.
And it's funny cause
when I got into fighting,
they,
I told the guys I was training with,
I said I want to go,
I want to fight one 30
fives and they're like,
we don't have one 35 and I was like,
well what about one 45 second?
I wouldn't have one 45 but it,
it really turned out to
be something good for me.
You know,
I,
because I was competing
when I was healthy,
I just felt like fighting.
I couldn't imagine going through a season
like wrestling and wanting to get in a
fight when I was 133 pounds,
you know?
He did not feel like fighting anybody.
You feel like,
like,
all right,
go ahead and take my
girlfriend and my money.
I'm going to sit over
here and think about food.
It's a horrible thing.
And during adolescence to that
kids go through and you know,
wrestling is the fucking,
they're starving themselves
while they're growing.
See,
I didn't start wrestling until the
eighth grade and then after that I didn't
even know that I was supposed to be
cutting weight as a freshman and sophomore
because our team socked in and it was
like I was the best guy on the team
anyways.
And so it was like,
just go wherever I wanted.
You know?
It's pretty funny.
When did you decide that you were
going to make a transition to MMA?
I decided they actually did,
they did an interview with me after my
senior year in college and they asked me,
um,
what was next for me.
And I've never been a guy
that has planned much,
you know,
I've just kind of like
just gone with the flow,
whatever I felt like doing,
doing.
But I remember saying,
I think I'm going to try
out mixed martial arts.
And there's actually an
article in the newspaper,
like the College newspaper.
I said,
I think I'm gonna try this,
this mixed martial arts thing out,
you know,
and,
uh,
it,
it was illegal in California.
And I started coaching at Uc Davis.
I was getting paid like $7,000 a year
as a full time job busing tables at a,
at all
$10,000 a year.
I thought it was a lot of money.
I mean,
I knew it wasn't a lot of money,
but it was more money than I was used to,
you know,
and I didn't feel like I was working.
And I started a little business called
top line coaching and I went and got some
uh,
like a little elementary school group
of kids that I started training.
And then I had a,
uh,
some camps that I,
that I put on the college that I,
that my coach let me put
them under my business name.
And so I actually was working like 16,
17 hour days in addition to training.
I was doing my full time Gig at Uc Davis
and I was coaching kids afterwards and
then I would go home and I'd bus
tables at this little bar called ink.
And My,
my rent was like 220 bucks
a month living there.
Wow.
And uh,
yeah,
it was crazy,
man.
And I started fighting.
At that time I had my
emergency teaching credential.
I was going to start teaching some,
you know,
be a substitute teacher a little bit,
but I took a fight,
made 450 bucks or 500 bucks,
200 to show 200 to win a 100
bucks for selling tickets.
And I was like,
make that in like a week,
you know?
That was like my monthly salary was,
was that,
so I,
that's,
that's when I hit the switch.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
Holy Shit.
And what year was this?
2003 you were how old?
I was 23 wow.
So you had like,
it was,
it was like,
it was more of a financial thing that,
that sent to you in,
well,
I could've got a job.
I just graduated from a major university
and I could have actually got a job.
It wasn't a financial thing.
It was like not worrying
about financial thing,
you know?
And it was like,
dude,
this was awesome.
I was like,
my first fight,
minute and a half,
I made,
you know,
almost 500 bucks.
I didn't tell my mom about it.
I didn't tell her about it.
She found out,
like I said,
I told her like two weeks later,
I said I had the little tape and I go,
mom,
I got something to show you.
And I,
and I sat her down,
I put the tape in and she's like,
what the heck?
And she's,
I'm in 23 at this point.
I've lived out of the
House since I was 18,
you know,
around,
and she's like,
please tell me you're not
going to do this again.
And I'm like,
you know,
kind of smirking and,
and she's like,
you're,
I will pay you not to do this,
that.
And she's,
and I said,
I said,
it's going to be 500 bucks
per minute and a half.
That's what you're
going to need to pay me.
No.
Did you have a lot of
striking training in that?
But at that point,
was it all just rustling?
No,
but I thought I was bad ass,
which is important.
You got to see if you look up my,
uh,
my second fight,
my first fight,
I tried to hold it together.
I like came out southpaw and I started
firing straight street punches and the
guy came to take me down and my,
and it ended so fast.
I was like amped up for
like an hour afterwards.
Like,
ah,
I wish it would've lasted longer.
I wish he had done this.
I wish I would've done that.
And,
uh,
so I said,
next fight,
I'm just going to strike.
And I had this guy,
uh,
who was like,
had been training quite a bit and knew
what he was doing but was just not a
tough guy.
Like,
I mean if you look at
him and you look at me,
you know,
not to judge books by the cover,
you knew I was going to win,
you know.
And so I just kept it
standing for seven minutes.
I beat the crap out of this guy.
It's,
it's horrible.
And it's like cat and
mouse like punching him.
I'm trying to help him up like re rear
end back like this and running at him
with a like a like a fist and
throwing haymakers it was crazy.
And you were going down training.
How much striking training
had you had by them?
Like about my first fight,
about a month,
a month,
but not real training.
Just like no one.
I was going to throw punches
and like working on myself.
And then,
uh,
you just worked with yourself?
I mean,
just like I was,
I've been in fights before.
I knew I could hit hard.
I have like a heavy right hand and I've
been a huge boxing fan my whole life,
so I knew what it looked like.
There was coordinated guy,
you know,
so,
uh,
I just thought no one would
be able to beat me up.
I'm like,
there's no way really
anybody's going to beat me up.
Wow.
That's pretty fucking confident.
What was it like when
you had your first loss?
Uh,
it didn't hurt,
but it was a little disorienting.
I went in and uh,
it was against Tyson Griffin.
We were fighting in a parking lot of a
casino up in northern California and it
was like,
it was like hot out.
And um,
I went in there in the first round,
I do like a superman punch and then I
need him in the face and I hit an inside
trip and I brought my head to the
outside and the Kingdom of the gladiator
challenge.
Guys were having trouble with the Cajun.
They were lazy and so they
took the black covering,
but they didn't put the padding over
the steel on the bottom of the cage.
So I did a head dive as I was taking,
uh,
Tyson Griffin down and
just slammed into the cage.
Oh my God.
And my head just started gushing blood
and seven staples after the fight,
it was eight seconds into the fight.
So eight seconds in the fight,
I'm just blood's gushing down my face
and I've got them in a guillotine and I'm
shaking my head like
this and I'm telling her,
Herb's a ref and I'm like,
herb,
my,
I'm busted open or I'm bleeding
or something like that.
So he breaks us in a,
in a guillotine position.
And I was odd to shape.
I mean,
I was all discombobulated and Ted
Williams comes in and I had sold like 300
tickets.
This is house making money at
this time was selling tickets.
I'd sold like 300 tickets to get here
is eight seconds into the fight and the
doctor comes in who end up being a
vet and Ted Williams comes in and he,
the doctor's looking at me and Ted goes,
is he okay?
And uh,
now he said,
are you okay?
The doctor said,
I said,
I'm not sure.
You tell me,
you know,
and uh,
and then Ted said,
he's fine,
he's fine.
And they just started the fight again
and then I don't remember anything.
I was just going crazy.
It was like a wild,
it was like a herb says one of the
best fights that guys have never seen.
It was just like a knockdown
drag out back and forth.
And I,
my Jujitsu instructor at the time,
Casio didn't,
didn't make it to the fight.
I just have my striking
coach at that time,
day Merino wool and I didn't
know what was going on.
It was like a close fight the
first and the second rounds,
uh,
you know,
it was probably one on
one for rounds and he,
my,
my coach is like,
you got to knock them out.
I don't have any knockout,
like any street series
knockouts at this point.
So I go in at the beginning of the third
round and just do like a jumping right
hand and he throws like a straight right,
right on the button and
drops me and I didn't go out.
But,
uh,
I was like,
like getting pounded on in.
The ref called it.
You were probably so fucked
up from the first shot.
You were able to fight three rounds.
That's what ties to the bar.
A metal I Tyson,
I had had like a little
beef after that for a while.
It was just kind of like,
because he felt like I was making excuses.
I'm like,
I didn't make it cause I was
telling the story like yeah,
I got seven staples in my head
after the fight and this and that.
I was like fighting like a wild animal.
And he's like,
his guys from his hometown were
saying I was making excuses.
I'm like,
I understand the lost the fight.
I'm just telling what really happened.
Not Saying,
oh we like had a fever or anything.
I really hit my head and he was huge.
You know,
he's got about 40 pounds
on me walking US Christ.
Yeah.
So wild west man of MMA though.
Those were the days,
man.
Those king in the cage events
were pretty fucking nuts,
ma'am.
Yeah.
Indian casino parking lot.
They would do it if it rained.
Did you ever see wet and wild?
Yes.
What the fuck is that
dude?
That was them just not wanting to give
money back to people and just let it,
yeah.
Yeah.
They had came in a casino
in the pouring rain,
I mean,
and it was a plastic cover,
so you'd go up,
guys would go out and try to throw kicks
and just fly through the air and in
their heads.
That is so crazy.
A lot of people didn't fight.
They said,
fuck this.
I'm going.
That would have been smart.
I wouldn't have,
I wouldn't have gone home,
but I would have wished I would have.
You know,
you get some stupid stupid
shit would like your,
when you're hungry,
like probably for anything,
you know,
just hungry for,
for,
for success.
They're like willing to do
anything before it even.
You see that in these levels.
It's just nuts.
Yeah.
That shit.
That's fucked up.
I mean,
that's why one of the reasons
why you need regulatory bodies,
he needs someone to come and go,
no asshole.
You're not going to have a
fucking outdoor fight in the rain.
What are you going to do
of lightening comes in?
Is that part of the battle?
Yeah,
no,
no.
At least if they're in the rain,
they should be able to fight in mud
or something.
It's just,
it's too,
too animalistic.
You know what,
we talked about our elbows
to the back of the head.
Um,
do you like the rules
the way they are now?
Like do you think that,
uh,
that,
that everything's good or do you think
that we should have like needs to a
downed opponent or is anything
you would like to add?
I think you should be able to do a nice
sit down opponent and even kick a guy
while he's down because I mean,
this is a fight.
The thing that's so intriguing about our
sport is that this is what would really
happen if you mess with someone
and they know what they're doing.
This is what you're going
to have to deal with.
And it is still that.
But um,
you know,
it's just,
it's like one of those things where
you gotta you gotta look out for people
safety,
but you don't want
people abusing the rules.
Like putting their knee down all of a
sudden and like putting their hand down.
It's like if you're in a bad position,
you should be able to have to react.
The only other argument I've heard that's
a against stomps and soccer ticks and
the ground is the cage.
They're like,
if you're going to have stops
and soccer kicks on the ground,
you should have a ropes so you could
slide in the ropes to avoid it.
You shouldn't have a spot where they
can shove your head up against it and
soccer kick you in the head
because it's not natural.
You should be,
you should be able to move around.
He shouldn't be able to use
the cage as an actual weapon,
which there's an argument in that
that at least in pride they could,
they could see the kick
common that they can move,
they can move.
Like if you're running into a wall,
you can't move.
You just going to get
soccer kicked in the head.
You know,
you could say,
well,
you should never let yourself
get into that position,
but it seems almost like you're using
the cage in a way that it probably isn't
that sad.
Yeah,
I could see that.
And I mean,
but in,
in reality,
and I always go back to,
and that's why I was good on Dominic
because this is really like the gladiator
days where it's like a simulated
fight to the Dominick Cruz
for folks who don't know is your,
uh,
last,
last time you guys fought,
it was a very close to decision.
A lot of people thought
you could have won.
A lot of people thought he could have.
Well,
we were very,
very close fight and you guys
were set to fight in the rematch.
But uh,
Dominic recently blew out his knee,
so now you're going to be
fighting Hanan Barao but yeah,
you've Cree criticized Dominic style.
It's like point fighting,
right?
I mean his,
you can't really criticize him too
much other than the fact that it's not,
I don't,
I feel like he could have
potential to finish some guys,
but he doesn't go for that.
And this is really a simulated fight.
I mean,
this is a fight to the death.
It's in Diaz says the same thing.
It's like if we were in
a fight to the death,
you know,
who'd win,
right.
You know,
and,
and at,
at that,
on that level,
like I'd like to see guys
try to finish all the time.
Right.
You know,
like play by the rules and this and that,
you know,
like,
like tag somebody and like it,
it looks like you're hurting him.
And I feel like Dominic has
potential to do some damage.
He just doesn't know how or doesn't try,
you know,
to finish.
It's a mentality thing.
Okay.
Now this,
this style of fighting where
you just go by and get points,
but,
but still,
when I mean it,
it can be effective for guys.
And what's it all for?
I mean,
how do you,
how do you make a distinction?
Like when do you decide
whether it's about,
it's all about being as entertaining
as possible or it's all about winning.
Like it seems to me that there's like,
I just don't feel like that's winning.
Ah,
so to you,
it's not honorable to try to like,
just point your way through it.
You're trying to,
Dominic for example,
is not,
it's not dishonorable.
I mean he's,
he's trying,
he's trying to do damage and
maybe just doesn't have it in him.
I don't know.
But the,
he makes fun of the size of his hands.
You know,
it makes fun of it.
We did an interview and he's say,
I got a bitch hands,
you know,
cause he broke his hand.
Yeah.
That's,
that's something,
there's nothing you can do about that.
Right.
I mean
there's nothing you can do about that.
But I mean,
I'm not taking anything away,
but I would say,
you know,
the,
the purpose of this sport is
like to finish and do damage.
And you can't really knock a guy
who's really great at what he does,
you know?
And,
and he is trying,
I mean,
I guess if you get a
guy that that crumbles,
he'd probably finish him,
you know?
But,
uh,
I like to go in with a mentality of,
of let's do war that's brow
is going to try to finish me.
I'm going to try to finish brow,
you know,
and it's going to be till the,
till the bitter end,
you know,
it's not going to be like pitter
pattering and stuff like that.
That's going to be a sick fight.
That's going to be a second.
Yeah,
I was looking at it and it's crazy.
It's like he has,
I think he has more fights in idea.
He's got 13 k,
He's got six submissions and he's got
like nine decisions and I've got 14
submissions,
a seven t,
k,
O,
k Ios,
and like four decisions.
There's preferred this fight.
It doesn't mean if you had a choice
between this fight in the fight with
Dominick Cruz,
I want this.
I want the fight that fans want to see.
And I think people afterwards,
I'm going to prefer this fight,
but we'll prefer the Dominick Cruz fight.
So I want to give people
what they want to see in,
you know,
Dominic and I have a history that we
need to solve and stuff like that.
I mean,
I was really looking
forward to fighting him.
But as far as an exciting fight goes,
this is going to be a crazy fight.
It's a funny thing,
this Dominic thing,
uh,
because,
I've never seen you be
upset by an opponent.
I've never seen you
trash talk and appalling.
And you know,
you're usually pretty easy going guy.
And when I've talked to
you about your opponent,
you're pretty analytical
about their skillset,
but,
but there's something about Dominick Cruz,
it gets under your skin.
But is it the,
I don't know if you
know the history of us,
but I know you won the first fight.
We got caught him to gates.
Well,
when I,
when I first time I met him was after he
was just being an immature little punk.
And this,
I mean,
I,
I'm like,
you know,
open to be cool with whoever.
I never met the guy,
I don't know him from Adam.
And he like kind of chose me as an enemy
and in the real world that guys in my
town,
we're going to do,
we're going to do some sort of battle,
you know,
or he's not going to do that.
You know?
And we did and it still didn't go away.
You know,
it's like the guy's got a chip on it so
I really believe he's jealous of me for
some shape or form.
And like I've sat there and talked to
them before and like he's like complain
about stuff and he's gotten a lot better
cause I think his situation has gotten
a lot better.
He's getting more notoriety and
more money and things like that,
but I think he's jealous,
you know?
And it,
it gets on my nerves.
Like,
dude,
you got plenty of great stuff going on
in your life and he's got to choose me as
the person he's going
to be negative about.
Is it that or is it just that that's
how he gets himself fired up to compete
against someone?
I don't care.
You don't care.
I mean,
I don't care what his,
what his money it is
to be a dickhead to me.
You don't be a dickhead to me,
period.
How was he being a dickhead?
Like what did he do?
Well,
okay,
so,
so the first time we fought
we signed those posters,
you know that story,
where were you sign?
Everybody takes home,
you know,
your certain amount of posters that you
put up in your gym and stuff like that.
They give some to
charity important people.
And he was pissed.
His face was on the poster.
There's four title fights that night
and say put all the champions on there.
And so he starts signing his name over
my face of the posters that everybody
takes home.
And so like that started and
then after the fight I beat him.
And then I've got friends in San Diego.
I was,
you know,
helping promote a fight in San Diego.
And all I hear is Dominic's running his
mouth and like talking crap about me.
I even thought about the guy,
you know,
and he's got my poster
up in his jam and he's,
you know,
defacing it.
And just like talk in chat and I'm like,
what is this guy's problem?
Like obsessing like he's got a
fucking hard on for me or something.
You know,
like,
dude,
I could give two shits about this guy,
but you fought him again.
And then we fought them in and
then I fought him again and uh,
I felt like I did more
damage in that fight.
And you know,
that the events prior to that fight kind
of let things set things to rest with
us because we had,
as it were,
forced to spend time together and this
whole camp Pendleton thing when we did
this crucible and like,
they're like tugging at her heartstrings
about the military and they put us
through this crazy workout and like,
you know,
that's when I actually got to get to
know him a little bit better and realize
like,
all right,
the guy,
the guy's coming from a place where he
feels like he's been misrepresented,
he's feels like he's underpaid,
he's mismanaged,
he's this and that.
And we actually had some good talks
and kind of put the the beef aside,
but I feel like there's still
a little jealousy there.
You know what I mean?
Had some good talks and he's
still like to fuck him up.
Oh yeah.
And vice versa,
you know?
That's really interesting.
So that must be a very strange thing to
be spending so much time with a dude.
You're about to go to war war.
It was weird in the,
you know what happened in like
slipped through the cracks.
It was like new PR people and the Marines
setting up this thing that was going
to be a a like a partnership with the
UFC and this and that and no one really
understood the fact that he and I were
fighting in a month and a half and
they're going to have us
working as a team together,
like going through this crazy crucible.
We did a third of the crucible,
which is like the like the initiation
ceremony where they put these guys through
hell for 50 hours and no
sleep and all this stuff.
Phil Davis,
Rich Franklin,
Dominic and myself had to go.
They're like,
okay,
we're going to shoot these guns
with La and meeting these marines,
whatever.
The next thing you know,
they're like,
we're going to do this obstacle course,
which is a small little obstacle course.
Go to meet the drill
sergeants and they're like,
you know,
they were not cracking a
smile and this and that.
They have to start doing this,
this uh,
this like short but intense,
uh,
whatever it's called,
obstacle course.
Then they throw backpacks on us
and we start our day marching,
whether yelling at us and all this stuff.
Then it goes to the next thing,
next thing,
next thing you know,
it's like 10 o'clock at night.
We'd been there for like nine hours
just getting like punk by these,
by these marines and like
crawling through dirt,
carrying fucking ammunition stuff.
Like,
like Dominic heard is he ran and got,
got hurt his knee tripping over
Bob Wire and he has his Christ.
We're all jacked up.
He had like his shoes didn't fit,
so we had like huge blisters on his feet
and I ended up hurting myself a little
bit.
I had a broken hand at the time.
I didn't know I was to
be doing this stuff.
I had a broken hand.
It was like a week and a half old,
just a little fracture.
And I did,
I climbed the top of the rope.
I did the pullups,
they did all this stuff because I didn't
want to tell my opponent that I had a
broken hand.
Oh my God.
So it was like,
man,
it was crazy.
That's ridiculous.
What is terrible idea?
Who the fuck put that together?
It was slipped through the cracks.
All new workers that UFC and like Redo it.
By the time I got in the middle of it
and everybody got in the middle of it,
it was like the marines,
they're like appreciate about America.
And it was like,
dude,
you know.
I was like,
just like Phil was laughing and,
and the,
and the guys like Phil,
you will stop laughing right now.
You will the blower blood in
like so he's trying not to laugh.
And the other guy says,
uh,
the other Joe Sergeant says,
Phil,
when he says,
stop laughing,
he means hide your teeth.
And then I start fucking laughing.
I'm like busting up laughing and,
and then,
and then so they're like,
Zap,
funny Mr Favor,
you think there's funny something
funny about Americans dying in war.
And then I'm like,
all right,
this is like,
okay,
this is right at the beginning.
Wow,
we're getting like this,
this whole thing that's
a Moronica sentence.
We had to do a,
yeah,
we had,
we had to do something,
uh,
where we like we're doing
these problem solving things.
We had to like communicate,
like one guy was the leader and we had
to like get these like big buckets past
the ropes and follow these rules and like
problem solve and like communicate as
a team.
So I,
by the end of the thing,
it was like we were cool and then,
you know,
we were like,
he's asking me advice about stuff and,
and really,
yeah,
vice versa.
And then we'll get her
advice and give him,
give him some shitty advice.
He would just,
I was,
he was complaining about his
mismanagement and all this kind of stuff.
And I was like,
dude,
just say I went through the same stuff.
He's like,
I've been fighting just as long as you,
I was there.
I met you when you fought
Charlie Valencia for the title.
You remember meeting.
I didn't remember meeting him or whatever.
And it was like,
he's like,
I,
I this and I that and just
feeling sorry for himself.
I'm like,
dude,
stop feeling sorry for yourself.
Do this.
And he's like,
well,
am I on the right track?
And I'm like,
yeah,
you're on the right track.
Do you just chill?
And uh,
and that was it.
And then we went our separate ways
and is back to being an enemies.
What a strange thing that must've been
preparing for a title fight with a guy
going through this.
This is like a bonding experience that
you didn't want to have and some guy
yelling at you.
Do you think it's funny when
Americans are dying at war?
It.
Fuck it.
Every time.
Every time you go to the funny,
right now this is funny.
This is funny.
We're not needing,
not preparing soldiers stupid,
which trying to give you
the authentic experience.
It must have been.
It wasn't tense row.
So it was intense.
Do they crack a smile afterwards over?
Yeah,
we all went out and had a,
had a good dinner and stuff like that.
And uh,
that was,
that was the last Dominic
I hung out and good terms.
Wow.
Been enemies ever since.
So this is before the rematch.
This is before the rematch.
How many times did you
drop him in that fight?
I times where I hit him on the
Chin and he dropped three times.
Three times.
That should be,
you know,
it's,
she should be fat,
right.
Anything I hadn't,
I had long hair.
Next time I fight him,
I'm not going to have my hair loose.
Cause every time,
you know,
in sparring I,
there's all times where you guys crazy,
you slip and you move and stuff like that.
But your hair goes for shakes.
Judges.
I mean these judges,
I don't even want to get started on that.
Don't even get started
cause I'll go crazy to go get,
get started.
Does it drive you nuts?
Oh my God.
Disrespect.
Right.
It's total disrespect.
I'm not going to start on it because I
see all these judges all the time and I
don't want them angry bias against me.
Yeah,
but like the comprehensive script.
Some of these judges that,
you know,
I've never wrestled,
never did judo and Jujitsu,
never done karate,
never done boxing.
And it's like,
why is my life in your hands and why?
Because the athletic commission
doesn't want to change.
What's what?
They feel like they already set in place.
I have to admit they fucked up.
They would have to admit
to these people are out.
Yeah,
they won't do it.
I mean it's,
it's mind boggling.
It's just a 50 50 chance they should,
they should have to review
fights and have to explain.
I mean,
it's a big goddamn deal.
You,
you train for a,
you know,
eight weeks plus for a
fight after every fight.
They should not have to only judge,
but explain what was going on.
They explain why you thought
that this was better than that.
I've been so tempted to grab one of
these judges that I know doesn't know
anything and ask them on camera.
Ask them a full interview of like,
what is an Omoplata?
What makes it,
what makes it work?
What makes it not work?
What is this?
Is this a dangerous position?
When does it become dangerous?
When is it not?
And you just like see where they're at.
Dude,
I see credit,
I don't want to say any names,
but one of the guys who's that judges
told me that a woman judge asked him what
is,
what is this guy doing?
Like I was attempting
and Kamora she's like,
what is he doing?
She had to ask what a guy's doing and
on top of that she doesn't know what it
felt like.
Whether it's going to hurt the
guy or whether it's just a or,
well,
yeah,
like you know when someone has a,
they got an Americana and it's
all up here and you're like,
you think he's going to be okay.
He's going to just kind of twisting his
arm and then the guy who holds it to the
body and you've got to
know that that's better.
Then once you get it to the body that's,
that's like a near submission.
There's so many guys out there that could
really use those jobs that really know
what Charlie Valencia,
for example,
my good buddy who's an
accomplished fighter,
been fighting for years,
knows the sport inside and out.
If he was a veteran,
yeah.
If it was a lucrative job,
yeah,
it should be to what it,
what a great judge he would be.
You know?
Absolutely.
Everything knows.
It feels like to get punched,
know whether you get hit
on the top of the header.
If you get hit on the chin,
you know Ricardo,
Amanda's doing that now.
That's great.
That's what they do is
absolutely fighters.
I agree with you 100% it's just there's
people that they might be able to never
have boxed and judge boxing,
you know,
but you have to study boxing and you
have to talk to experts and stuff.
But I don't think it's possible for you
to know what the fuck is happening in a
cage fight unless you have
some martial arts experience.
I know a lot of,
a lot of grappling,
mixed martial arts,
a lot of grappling that,
what does that say?
It's five.
I can't read that.
Shirts.
Brian's hold little bit side.
It looks like fucking Hieroglyphs Joe,
do you ever watch the king of the cage
and glad you're challenged stuff now or
is it just,
it's not even,
it's not what it used be back
when I was starting,
when I was in gladder
challenging king of the case.
That was the only other show in town,
right?
It was like the UFC and then them
and then whatever's in Japan.
I still watch a small fights though,
are still watching.
Hd Net has a lot of small
organizations that uh,
come on.
They have,
you know,
you get to see like a rich Clemente.
I just saw him fight and I
just saw Dave branch and uh,
Anthony Johnson there a fucking dude.
He's got to weight cutting issue.
Wow.
I've never seen anybody up a weight class
and they keep missing this Guy Anthony
Rumble Johnson says
incredibly talented guy.
Weighs about two 30 ish before he
begins his cut down to one 70 shit.
I saw him walk through
the hallway once in a,
I'm in a hotel,
we're all,
I think it was in Denver.
He was so god damn big.
He wasn't fighting.
You know,
I couldn't believe how big he was.
I was like,
that dude is like a heavyweight.
It's amazing that he can make one 70
it's crazy.
Well I,
the reason I asked is I remember,
cause it's cool that you do watch his
fights because I don't remember before I
was in the WC or the UFC,
I remember you saying something
in recognizing me and,
and,
and like being like,
Hey,
I've seen you fight and this and that.
Which I thought was the coolest
thing in the world because,
you know,
it was like,
man,
these guys are watching.
You know?
And it's funny cause I was at a UFC in
Sacramento and I had a fake pass made
from my buddy Vinny,
the hook think pass all the time.
It was the best thing ever.
It was in sac and I,
uh,
I had gotten in with the pass and
then I just beeline straight through,
act like I own the
place and I'm in on the,
in the circle with Dana,
right,
with Dana and Lorenzo and all you guys.
And Dana's like,
hey,
how are you having a good time kid?
I'm like,
yeah,
having a good time,
you know,
and just chill out on the Internet
in a little circle with my fake pass.
Oh,
that's awesome.
And it was awesome.
And then,
uh,
like because I was just at a point where
I was making a name for myself and the
low,
the smaller shows that,
you know,
made a little bit of
sense that I was there,
you know what I mean?
So people didn't really
question it too much.
Like you had,
you had watched this a couple when I
was on little paper views and stuff,
but yeah,
that was the first time I think.
Yeah,
I'd seen you in the king of the cage.
I saw you.
I think I saw you live once
and I saw you on TV or on.
That was back when my friend bud own the
king owned a piece of the candy case.
So you guys had tapes laying
around so I saw most of them.
Eddie was doing commentary back then too.
Yeah,
that's right.
Yeah.
That's funny though.
Dana was like,
yeah,
no,
no idea.
I was just walking
around and they're like,
I own the joint days.
Like you having a good time kid.
I'm like,
yes.
Yeah,
maybe.
Yo,
you were right.
You did belong there.
Look now here we are promoting
a fucking huge fight.
Belonged there.
Of course you did.
Absolutely.
Now what,
what is the date of your,
uh,
your fight with brow?
It's a July 7th.
July 7th.
It's the same card is a Anderson
Silva Chelsea on a rematch.
That's going to be a crazy card.
Yeah.
It's going to be there.
They've been moved to our card,
which is awesome.
Yeah.
He's going to make it one of
the biggest in UFC history.
A huge card which goes into,
those are two monster fire's right there.
How did the,
uh,
how did the Jon Jones,
Rashad Evans fight?
Dude,
you're pretty good on paper.
I think it did really well.
I think they were surprised
at how well it did.
I think it exceeded expectations.
I think be Jon Jones is,
you know,
obviously on his way to
becoming a huge superstar.
That's a,
that's a rare gem of a talent right there.
And that you see a guy who's been
training for four years in MMA and he's,
you know,
choking Leo Machida
unconscious like God damn.
But you know,
his wrestling pedigree was really good.
He was supposed to go with a
scholarship to Iowa and you know,
because he's,
and he started his family instead.
And uh,
but he,
he,
he could have been a great rest or
collegiate wrestler at a high level also.
So,
no doubt.
But what's impressing me is how
God damn good at striking is.
And how good God,
how quick it got.
Good.
I mean it was great.
It was great when he fought Stephan
Bonner and he would fuck goose smile.
He was,
you know,
his striking look good it but it,
but it's become insane.
You know,
he out strikes shogun out
strikes rampage and you know,
it makes it look easy and that height
and reach is so hard to fuck with men.
Yeah.
It's crazy man to have you talked to
him since his situation he's Dui and for
those who don't know,
crashed into a pole apparently.
Yeah,
he's,
he uh,
he's been hard to get ahold of.
Like,
you know,
he's is a,
he's like changes his number all
the time and stuff like that.
I really talked to him in a long time,
not since I've seen him in person,
but yeah,
it's suck him.
He's a young guy.
I W I did an interview and they read
me this thing that he said like a week
before and uh,
yeah,
which is crazy and it makes me seem,
almost makes me feel like he
did it on purpose just to like,
like add to the story.
It's like,
why would you be like,
dude,
I will,
I'm so happy to do this because I will
never get a Dui then like a week later,
get it
Dui.
That's crazy.
I think it's pressure,
man.
I think,
uh,
especially if you're,
you know,
you're a young guy and you don't,
he's incredibly talented and the success
must be overwhelming to a few years ago
have gone from having to be a
bouncer to take care of your,
your girlfriend and your new baby,
you know,
and you're really worried
about your future.
So you decided to start fighting from
that just a few years ago to drive in a
Bentley top of the fucking world.
Everybody wants to shake your hand and
the world is stepping forward to John.
John's a shake his hand and he's see him,
he's got a glow around them.
An Aura.
That's a hard the
management and it's hard.
Yeah.
Was it hard for you?
You know,
it's not hard for me because I
surround myself with the same people.
Like,
you know,
my dad lives right next door
to me and all my buddies.
I mean I like my team of guys.
We started together,
you know,
Joseph was mopping the mats that are at
our gym and an amateur when he started.
And Chad Mendez,
I recruited out of college and
Tj recruited out of college.
Me and Danny Castillo
were high school buddies.
And um,
I have the same people around me
and you guys all have,
you have like a couple of houses and
y'all live close to each other too.
Yeah.
Or the overtime.
It's starting to change now because
guys are getting older and getting more
money and getting married and
getting all sorts of stuff.
But we've had like a
little commune that was,
uh,
it was really cool.
We call it the block and,
and uh,
it's a tight knit group.
You know,
we have our,
we have a charity golf tournament.
We're having a charity golf tournament.
It's the second annual we have,
uh,
that's a week after my fight.
We have a end of the year banquet
where we give out awards and like give
speeches to everybody,
to two guys and like real favorites
and everybody gets dressed up.
We have a big dinner.
So it's a whole gym.
Everybody trains there.
Is that what it is?
It's the whole team.
And then whoever wants to buy a dinner
to come and be a part of it and,
and uh,
we acknowledge everybody who does their,
their,
their little parts and,
and we have like houseboat trip.
So I mean it's like a
real tight knit crew.
So I mean,
it's hard also when you got a guy
like Tj Dillashaw for example,
who just started training like two and a
half years ago and I have a bad day and
he's kicking the crap out of me.
You know,
it's like hard to get on a high horse,
you know,
it's like,
how did you start this
whole commune thing?
How did you,
this the block,
how did you,
uh,
I thought was,
I saw once in one of the countdown shows.
I was like that it's fucking cool.
What a smart thing.
Like surround yourself with a bunch of
cool guys when you train with y'all live
together,
right?
It was,
it was basically,
so I talked about when I
first graduated college,
I started a little business top
line coaching for kids and it,
my coach at the time,
Lenny's Leschi allowed me to run
a summer of summer camps for the,
uh,
for the college through my business.
And that gave me like $40,000 that went
in and out and I got to keep like 3007
or something like that.
But then I that established them some
credit in the history work history and I
ended up buying my first house when
I was making on paper $7,000 a year.
Colin,
he can buy a house shit.
So,
you know,
but I was hustling.
I mean,
I was always able to make money and I
filled it with all my buddies to help pay
the rent.
And,
uh,
then my buddy Tommy,
who's back there,
he works for me full time.
We knew each other in
high school and college.
He was just graduating and was out of
a job or he wanted to buy a house house
opened up next door and my
other buddy bought that one.
And then I started doing better
about the house next door to that.
My other buddy,
uh,
Sanchez who started out as
like my nemesis in college,
like we were enemies like two and two.
My senior year,
he's like put me out of
my senior year in college.
Like only got to make me
cry and competition cause
it was like the end of my
college career,
he ends up coming and taking my spot at
Uc Davis and living with me renting a
room.
Wow.
And then he starts managing my gym and
then we bought another house right there
together.
I put the down payment,
he makes the payments and he
started a little business in there.
This is all my book.
You're going to love my book by the way.
It's,
it's money lost.
But,
uh,
so
he starts the name of it for everybody.
The business,
the book of the books,
laws of the ring,
your I laws and the laws of the ring.
Yeah.
And it's all these,
it's all these theories about
community and personal credit and,
and positive attitude.
That's the motivational book really.
Yeah.
Awesome.
So it's not just a,
this is how I,
you know,
became successful.
There it is right there.
And uh,
so,
so Sanchez starts,
this starts this company
in one of our garages,
like maintaining bank owned property
lawns and next thing you know,
he's the largest company in
the u s right now for that.
He's just caked out.
So cat,
he just becomes like
a crazy lawnmower guy.
He's,
he's mowing lawns from
Hawaii to Iowa to really,
he did,
they do like 33,000 or
35,000 some stupid number.
And that's all on the block.
And we've had all sorts of
stuff that's come off the block.
Chad Mendez lives on the block.
Tj Dillashaw.
We've had like 30 guys,
Korean Zombie came and stayed out there.
How many houses is it?
It's four houses right next to each other.
And then there's one house that's my
college buddy that's about a block and a
half.
That's so bad ass to have so many people
around you that you can count on all
the time too.
You know,
he trained with,
you know him,
he can count on them.
Yeah,
it's awesome.
It's cost me some money over the years,
like being the bank for
these guys now you know,
guys aren't always a pay
rent and stuff like that,
but I mean it built something
today that's super solid.
I mean our team now is one of
the top in the world and uh,
you know,
it was all part of that carpooling
to the gym and you know,
if you need to go,
you have no food,
go to one of the houses and
take somebody else's.
I mean man,
as long as everybody is
actually contributing.
Right.
And everybody has a place in
a function and a part of it.
Yeah.
Now you,
you have a gym,
you have your own gym
set up and what does,
what does your gym called
its ultimate fitness,
ultimate fitness.
And regular people can go
and train there as well.
It's like you have classes and shit.
Yeah we have like
uh,
we have,
you know,
quite a few,
quite a few members,
like 400 something members and
it's been around five years now.
We've,
we've,
you know,
grown it.
It's,
it's got a great reputation.
It's pretty bad.
Do you,
are you the one who's managing everything?
Like do you make your own
training scheduled that you
put everything together?
Do you have like an MMA coach who
handles like when you're going to do more
anti,
when you're going to wrestle,
when you're going to combine them,
do you have someone who analyzes you?
We have like a,
we have a team schedule and then
I have my individual coaches.
Like I have a Jujitsu coach,
have a master tongs,
my standup coach and,
and we have set times with our team where
we ever team practices that are pretty
structured.
And then we have our individual
stuff that we do outside of it.
So I'll do,
you know,
the set practices,
which are the pro practices
three days a week in the morning.
And then two days of sparring and then
we have two days of Jujitsu and then
everything else is of mix and
match.
We have a ricin class for guys
that need to do more wrestling.
But you don't have a person
who sets it all up for you.
You do it all for yourself.
How much you,
um,
you set your own strength and conditioning
schedule or did you bring in a guy
for that?
I've got a guy,
well I've got an individual
coaches for everything.
I've got a Russell Dunning's,
my strength and conditioning guy.
He's my physical therapist.
And the how do you decide,
like when you go to him,
when you do Moitai,
how do you do it by your body?
Do you do it by what you
know from your experience?
I said a general schedule and then
listen to my body outside of that.
So if I feel like I
need to do more or less,
I'll do more or less.
But um,
like said it a general schedule that
I know is always going to be there.
And then if I need to take a day off,
I'll just let someone know
or if I need to do more,
I'll just call someone up and we all
kind of do that same thing at the team.
You know?
It's like,
uh,
we have all these different things
available and you can hit them all.
That's what,
that's what makes our team really
unique is we're training all year round.
If you don't have a
fight and you're in town,
like you just go to practice,
you know it's,
it's what you do.
Everybody trains.
Nobody takes time off
and gets fat and stupid,
but you can't.
Yeah.
You can't anymore.
I can't chat.
Everyone has to be improving too.
Right?
Yeah.
This is the biggest gains like that.
Isn't that incredible for you to watch
when you started fighting to today and
see how crazy the sport has become me?
I remember when I used to watch,
you know,
when I saw your fights and king
of the cage or back in that day,
nobody knew what the
fuck cage fighting was.
No,
it was crazy.
I was like embarrassed.
It wasn't like you could pick up chicks,
at least the chicks.
I like.
You can pick up chicks by Tom.
You're a cage fighter.
How they were thinking
about a piece of shit.
Human dog keep that on the DL,
you know,
they get to know you
better now it's like chic.
I saw this video with Charlise thrawn
and she was talking about how much she
loves the UFC and I was like,
how fucking tweet did you tweet that?
No,
no,
no.
It's on the underground.
It was a mighty,
well a lot of people tweeted,
I think because the video was her on the
Conan O'brien show and she was talking
about how much she loves watching filing
and he could see Colin like he's a
little bit uncomfortable with it.
You know,
cause like when chicks start talking
about like fucking savage men beating the
fuck a guy like Conan,
like on,
uh Huh.
Yeah,
he doesn't even want to know that exists.
He certainly doesn't want them to
be coming out of the mouth of the,
one of the most beautiful
women in the world.
What he's trying to impress her.
Hey,
that's mother nature though.
It's a bench goes back to,
uh,
to the old instincts,
the wounded,
the wounded antelope,
this trace by the waterhole
get live forever,
bitch.
It is what it is.
That's,
how did you come up with the
name Alpha male Alpha male?
I,
while I was a human development major and
I just was studying all this different
stuff in school and I just
liked what it represented.
You know what I,
you know,
took cultural anthropology,
physical anthropology and all
these different development
classes and stuff like
that.
Like my whole was just about
people,
you know,
and,
and things and how things happen,
you know.
And uh,
I remember learning about these birds.
Like there's these,
there's this certain type of bird where
these three birds land and the two
sidekicks,
they all do this dance together
and then the two side kicks,
kick rocks in the middle one gets laid,
you know,
it's like,
it's choreographed.
These guys might have their opportunity
at sometime when it steps up and it's
their turn.
And then they talk about like these
packs of wolves that work together as a
team.
And then there's like the,
the big macho gorilla that that
like is spreading a seat in.
And there's like the
little sneak dick monkeys,
the guys that look at your runs in and
gets his hump in and like all these
different crazy stuff.
And like,
it was just interesting to me about how
in humans there's this Alpha males in
every category.
I mean there's an Alpha male ballerina,
there's an Alpha male,
a frigging gay dude,
there's an Alpha Male,
you know,
whatever.
There's this like the top
dog in every category in,
it's kind of trips me out of how they are,
but it takes like being smart,
being good looking and being persuasive,
being hardworking and being,
you know,
all these great things.
And I figured that's the shit.
It is honest in its approach.
I mean,
that is what everybody is trying to do.
Whereas you know you,
you can,
you can name it a bunch
of different things.
But yeah,
it is trying to be the Alpha male.
It's been the connotation of the
word that's sort of changed lately.
It's gotten,
it's become a tad douchey.
The word Alpha you,
it's like a,
you know,
to do that.
So Alpha,
I like people like rag on you from that.
You never heard anybody say that.
That's,
people say that on online.
A lot like to rag on you
for something to that.
So Beta,
you're a Beta,
you're being a Beta
Alpha and Beta is like a,
it's a,
it's a very,
oh that's right Brian.
It's kind of recent.
I mean I say that obviously
because we have a alpha brain,
it opens itself up to criticism.
That is what you're doing man.
You're,
you're,
you're Alpha male and the
motherfucking shit out of dudes.
Yeah.
And I mean it basically that's what it
comes down and like who's it takes all
that.
So he takes like intelligence,
athleticism,
some hard work,
dedication and like you know the guys
that rise to the top in anything are,
you know,
made up of that same stuff.
Whether it's like the top writer,
the top journalists,
the top anything
they are.
But I think that one of the most difficult
past in the world is the one that
you've found success in.
I think you are in one of the most
difficult businesses on the planet earth.
It's
rough if it's not physically,
it's mentally taxing.
It's,
it's a financially taxing when
you're getting going and that's,
that's the crazy thing.
I actually want to talk about that.
I've got a new thing that Phil Davis
and I are starting called MMA draft and
we've been working on it for a long time,
but it's basically going to create
opportunities for these up and comers.
It's like MMA draft is going to take
a guy like Phil Davis was a national
champion and start following
his career when he's a kid.
Give him opportunity to like
shine as a kid and be like,
these are the top MMA prospects and start
covering all these different amateur
sides,
Jujitsu,
wrestling,
uh,
I think we should even
cover some soccer stuff.
And there's so many soccer athletes
coming in there kicking man,
just the deck story with the
legs and stuff like that.
But they need to start,
we need to start finding like the next
tiger woods and Lebron James and Michael
Jordans of our sport and watch them grow
up as kids so that when a guy like Phil
or a guy like,
uh,
you know Chad Mendez who's a national
finalists or Lance Palmer who's a national
finalists and wrestling,
it doesn't have to wash dishes and mow
lawns for the first four or five fights
before there's an opportunity there.
So developing this whole
a website where we're,
we're,
we're having criteria and we're having
like profiles and we're going to create
some ourselves and do our scouting and
like cover events of kids from youth all
the way through,
you know,
the international wrestling and Jujitsu
and kickboxing and amateur leagues.
It.
Dude,
it's going to be crazy or we have
a temporary side of right now.
You can check it out and what does it
MMA draft.com [inaudible] dot com but
we're working on it.
It's good.
It's going to be sweet and one more time.
Your book is laws of the ring laws
of the ring and they can get that on
amazon.com Amazon on,
I'm actually doing a signing tonight
at Barnes and nobles in Huntington.
Me leaving right now to go to that.
You're going to have to get on the fucking
terrible highway of five o'clock in
the Los Angeles.
Yeah,
that's rough.
Barnes,
noble,
Huntington beach.
Seven o'clock.
Yup.
Go meet Uriah favor.
Get your heartbroken too.
It was awesome.
Really Fun interview.
Thank you very much.
Great fucking stories and best
of luck and the brow fighter.
Appreciate it man.
It's going to be awesome.
All right,
one more little plug here to my guys.
I'm working on this new brand of equipment
and lifestyle stuff called torque.
We're going to come out with
all sorts of new badass stuff,
so keep your eye open for that.
At the torque one.
Dot Net is in the makes right now.
We're going to have mats.
We're going to have gloves.
It's going to be awesome.
And what is your main website?
A torque one.net.
And my partner is actually
the guy that started Bsn,
uh,
Scott James and he's an
incredible businessman.
He sold that company for a
lot of cash and he wants,
he just loves him in May.
And so,
uh,
that's who I'm going to be
rocking from here on out.
Boom.
And make sure you follow
your eye on Twitter.
It's your Riaa Faber.
You could spell a pitch.
Google it if you can.
I'm tired of explaining things to people.
Thank you to the fleshlight
for sponsoring our podcast,
Joe rogan.net.
Click on the link and
then decode ne Rogan.
Save 15%.
Thank you to on.com uh,
and again,
uh,
click on the link on Joe Rogan.
Dotnet entering the coke name,
Rogan enter into Coney road.
Excuse me,
enter in the code name Rogan.
Save yourself 10% off.
We will be back tomorrow
with John Anthony West.
That'll be the last podcast of the week.
But we also have the ice house chronicles.
We did one last night.
It was fucking awesome.
And we do them almost every time we
have a show here at the ice house,
they're available.
Uh,
if you subscribe to death
squad on Itunes and uh,
there are also available
usually on my Ustream,
but sometimes on red bands as well.
So follow red band,
get all that information.
That's r e d B a n on Twitter and go to
death squad.tv and buy yourself a fancy
new desk squad tee shirt.
Hell yeah.
You got one of those Brian?
I can show people right now.
Yeah,
right behind you on the
storm trooper that folks,
can you see that shit?
It's a pretty sport and
we have Eliza Friday.
Oh.
Slash or just coming.
Who else is coming?
We have Justin Markdale,
Sam Tripoli.
Randy's coming back.
Tony Hinchcliffe.
Johnny rotten is coming to,
he's going to come and sit in awe and
I'm trying to get crystal McGuire to come
and hang with us as well
and sit in on the podcast.
I'm the icehouse chronicles the,
it's free.
You can watch it again
on this Ustream page.
Mine wrote Joe Rogan,
or you can download it on
iTunes under desk squad.
It's only available on a desk squad.
So subscribe.
We'll see you dirty bitches tomorrow
with one of my personal heroes,
John Anthony West,
the great Egyptologists were going to
fucking get to the bottom of shit and then
we'll see you later on that
night at the icehouse chronicles.
I talk too much.
Bye.
Hi.